Well, you know I just can't get enough of that opening song. I just think it's just great. It's under our voices right now. Can you hear it right under us? Yeah, it's just kind of gets me going. Oh, I'm being real buoyed by this. Well, you always call me a robot. It's kind of like my little theme song, right? I know. Yeah, it is like a little thing for a little robot thing, but it's playing underneath us right now. It's going to kick it in a second, kick it in. Three, two, one.
好吧，你知道我就是听不够那首开场曲。我觉得它太棒了。它现在就在我们的声音下面。你能听到它就在我们下面吗？是的，它让我很有动力。哦，我真的被它鼓舞了。好吧，你总是叫我机器人。这就像我的小主题曲，对吧？我知道。是的，它就像一个小机器人的小东西，但它现在就在我们下面播放。它马上就要开始了，准备好。三，二，一。
Now, so we had a little record earlier today and now we're having our second record. There was a gap in between where lunch usually sits and I always whenever this happens, I'd love to know what Sean had. Oh, good. I had chicken curry with rice and cauliflower and sweet potatoes. And then I had a huge bowl of ice cream after. Wait, you had chicken curry with rice? Yeah. I did not, I did not know that Chef, we already made that. That's funny.
好了，我们今天早些时候录了一次，现在是第二次录音。中间有一段通常是午餐的时间，每当这种情况发生时，我都想知道肖恩吃了什么。哦，很好。我吃了咖喱鸡配米饭、花椰菜和红薯。之后我还吃了一大碗冰淇淋。等等，你吃了咖喱鸡配米饭？是的。我不知道，我不知道主厨，我们已经做过那个了。真有趣。
That's true. But you see, I didn't change. I still, I'm still in my smart list. Yeah, smart list merch. There's some good stuff in there. I was, I guess I shouldn't be surprised because we looked at it all before it went in there, but let me tell you something. I slept in this shop, shopsmartlist.com. It's the best. It's, it's, it's sleepable. Is that what it is?
那是真的。但你看，我没换衣服。我还是，我还在穿我的SmartLess周边。是的，SmartLess周边。里面有些好东西。我猜我不应该感到惊讶，因为我们在它上架之前都看过，但我得告诉你一件事。我穿着这件衣服睡觉，shopsmartlist.com。它是最好的。它，它，它适合睡觉。是这样吗？
Wait, is it shopsmartlist.com for real? Shopsmartlist.com. Yeah. What's it again? Sorry, Sean. What'd you say? Shopsmartlist.com. It's great.
等等，真的是shopsmartlist.com吗？Shopsmartlist.com。是的。再说一遍是什么？抱歉，肖恩。你说什么？Shopsmartlist.com。太棒了。
I'm telling you, are you sleeping the sweats? You put the hat on when you roll out of bed. It's great. Who, did you design the blanket, those big heavy blankets? You did, right? You wanted the heavy blanket. I didn't design them, but I, what's that? You wanted the heavy blanket.
我跟你说，你穿着运动服睡觉吗？你起床时戴上帽子。太棒了。谁，是你设计的毯子吗，那些又大又重的毯子？是你设计的，对吧？你想要那条重毯子。我没设计它们，但我，什么？你想要那条重毯子。
I wanted the heavy blanket because I have an issue with a throw blanket. A throw blanket covers one leg. Right. So I never understood the, the, the function of a throw blanket. No, I'm saying I like it because it's, it's, it's weighty. Yeah. It's weighty and it's big. It covers your whole body.
我想要那条重毯子，因为我对盖毯有意见。盖毯只能盖住一条腿。对吧。所以我从来没理解过盖毯的功能。不，我是说我喜欢它，因为它，它，它有分量。是的。它有分量而且很大。它能盖住你的全身。
And it's, it's like, what do you call it? Warm fleece. Like fleece, I guess. Yeah. Hey, by the way, you know what I did? Oh, definitely whisper. Yeah. Okay.
而且它，它就像，你怎么称呼它？暖和的抓绒。就像抓绒，我想。是的。嘿，顺便问一下，你知道我做了什么吗？哦，一定要耳语。是的。好的。
That's going to be. For Scotty, I got him a surprise. For Scotty. I got John Williams, the composer. Yeah. To sign a page of the ET score for Scotty. Jesus. How'd you do that?
那将会是。为了斯科蒂，我给他准备了一个惊喜。为了斯科蒂。我找了作曲家约翰·威廉姆斯。是的。为斯科蒂签了一页《E.T.》的乐谱。天哪。你是怎么做到的？
A friend of mine knows his friends with his daughter and then we just kind of made it happen. Are you guys good at that? Are you good? It sounds like you are, Sean, where you, you sort of like, you remember what your, your friend or partner or kid or whatever he really loves. And you work on it for a few months. Yeah. And you get the perfect gift.
我的一个朋友认识他的女儿，然后我们就促成了这件事。你们擅长这个吗？你们擅长吗？听起来你很擅长，肖恩，你，你就像，你记得你的朋友、伴侣或孩子或其他什么人真正喜欢什么。然后你为此努力几个月。是的。然后你得到了完美的礼物。
Like, do you do that every year? I love doing that. Yeah. Really? Yeah. Hey, Will, you don't need to go up high like everybody in the world does it except you, Jason. I don't do it.
比如，你每年都这样做吗？我喜欢这样做。是的。真的吗？是的。嘿，威尔，你不需要像世界上每个人那样表现得高高在上，除了你，杰森。我不那样做。
So that's why I'm saying. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Will is very good at throwing money at a gift. Of course, Sean. And I am very good at that. You're very good at that.
所以我才这么说。是的，没错。是的。是的，威尔非常擅长用钱砸礼物。当然，肖恩。我非常擅长那个。你非常擅长那个。
Whereas Sean, you, you'll do sort of a sentimental thing or I remember you said in July that what you wanted for Christmas was. That's right. Like I clocked, I clocked last year for, for Maple's birthday. She said, she just mentioned that she loved skateboarding. So I got her skateboard or a certificate for a skateboarding thing. Yes. And we went and spent the hell out of that.
而肖恩，你，你会做一些感性的事情，或者我记得你在七月说过你圣诞节想要什么。没错。就像我去年记录了梅普尔的生日。她说，她只是提到她喜欢滑板。所以我给她买了滑板或者滑板课程的证书。是的。然后我们去那里玩得非常开心。
Did you? That's how she broke all her teeth. Remember? Yeah. Thanks, Sean. Yeah. You should just get her teeth out. That's why she's got those flippers now.
真的吗？她就是那样摔断了所有的牙齿。记得吗？是的。谢谢你，肖恩。是的。你应该直接把她的牙齿拔掉。这就是她现在戴着假牙的原因。
And we've got this memory of her and she takes her teeth out every night. She thinks of you when she has to take him out. By the way, though, back to the ice cream thing. Yeah. I didn't tell you this. Jay, last episode we recorded, you, we talked about you having their, what is it called? The root canal. Yeah.
我们有关于她的这段记忆，她每天晚上都要把牙齿拿出来。她每次拿出来的时候都会想到你。顺便说一下，回到冰淇淋的话题。是的。我没告诉你这个。杰，我们录制的上一集，你，我们谈到了你做了那个，叫什么来着？根管治疗。是的。
I had a cavity. You had one. And I just got, yeah, just last week. And I got a crown. Not possibly your first. No. Oh my God. I have so many.
我有个蛀牙。你有一个。我刚，是的，就在上周。我做了一个牙冠。可能不是你的第一个吧。不。天哪。我有好多。
But it's 52 years old. Oh, they're going to start coming fast. That is strange. Let's take a look at your diet. Yeah. But what is strange about things on your body degenerating as you get older? Well, but I floss and I brush and I do everything. So it's like, why don't teeth teeth don't play by that?
但它已经52岁了。哦，它们会开始很快坏掉的。这很奇怪。让我们看看你的饮食。是的。但随着年龄增长，身体部位退化有什么奇怪的？好吧，但我用牙线，我刷牙，我做了一切。所以就像，为什么牙齿不按那个规律来？
No, because they're sitting in sugar all day. Yeah. I will say this. You're having ice cream when you're having dessert for lunch. Yeah. Breakfast. You have a situation. He had dessert for breakfast the other day.
不，因为它们整天泡在糖里。是的。我得说这个。你午餐吃甜点时在吃冰淇淋。是的。早餐。你有个情况。他前几天早餐吃了甜点。
I did have a thing where one of my favorite sweeteners that I use, I don't want to say which one with my coffee because I thought, oh, I'm not having sugar for a few years. I've been using a sweetener. And I see that one of its ingredients, this study came out yesterday, a huge study saying that it causes like strokes and heart attacks. Yeah. Oh, I saw that.
我确实有一件事，我用的最喜欢的甜味剂之一，我不想说具体是哪一种，因为我以为，哦，我几年没吃糖了。我一直在用一种甜味剂。然后我看到它的成分之一，昨天出了一项研究，一项巨大的研究说它会导致中风和心脏病。是的。哦，我看到了。
Yeah. Really? I know. Yeah. I'm so fucking bummed. So you don't want to say this publicly since it's already public? Well, just because it's an, so I don't want to call out the one particular brand. Yeah.
是的。真的吗？我知道。是的。我真是他妈的沮丧。所以你不想公开说这个，既然它已经公开了？好吧，只是因为它是一个，所以我不想点名那个特定的品牌。是的。
Yeah. It's being reported on or whatever. Yeah. Oh, so the sweetening component is the problem, not the brand. Right. One of the ingredients. So then what is the ingredient? Do you remember?
是的。它正在被报道什么的。是的。哦，所以甜味成分是问题所在，而不是品牌。对。成分之一。那成分是什么？你记得吗？
I forget what it's called. Agave. No. Is it agave? No. It's in a lot of, it's in a lot of sort of stevia-centric sweeteners. Really? Yeah.
我忘了它叫什么了。龙舌兰。不。是龙舌兰吗？不。它在很多，它在很多以甜菊糖为中心的甜味剂里。真的吗？是的。
Yeah. Is that what you're using? Yeah. So, so a lot, I don't know if purest, I don't know, but I know that some of them have it in anyways. Guys. I know. Kind of real uplifting, huh?
是的。那是你在用的吗？是的。所以，所以很多，我不知道Purest是不是，我不知道，但我知道其中一些确实含有它。伙计们。我知道。挺让人振奋的，对吧？
Are we ready for our guest? Oh, I guess let's get to the guest. Sure. Before I die, let's get it done. At least we'll know why. Exactly. I got to say, I get some of the best guests. This guy has had not one.
我们准备好迎接嘉宾了吗？哦，我想我们开始吧。当然。在我死之前，让我们把它完成。至少我们会知道原因。没错。我得说，我请到了一些最好的嘉宾。这家伙不仅有一次。
Did you write this intro? Did you write this intro? This is the intro, yeah. Did you write it? Yeah. This guy has had not one, but two songs written about him by a huge pop star. Most would agree he's Hollywood royalty, being an Academy Award-winning filmmaker, a happy-hitting movie star who's portrayed a very famous DC comic book character onscreen
是你写的这段介绍吗？是你写的这段介绍吗？这是介绍，是的。是你写的吗？是的。这家伙不仅有一首，而是两首由超级流行歌星为他写的歌。大多数人会同意他是好莱坞的皇室成员，是一位获得奥斯卡奖的电影制作人，一位票房大卖的电影明星，曾在银幕上多次扮演一个非常著名的DC漫画角色。
multiple times. I knew it is. But most importantly, just an all-around great guy that I'm so happy to call a friend who I love a whole bunch and I know you fellas do too. Please welcome to smart list Mr. Benjamin, Gays of Affleck Bolt. Oh, no. No. There he is.
我知道是谁了。但最重要的是，他是一个全方位的好人，我很高兴称他为朋友，我非常爱他，我知道你们伙计们也一样。请欢迎来到SmartLess，本·盖斯·阿弗莱克·博尔特先生。哦，不。不。他来了。
Oh, I love him. I love him. Very nice. That was... Your second, how did Sean get you and I don't? God damn it. Because I like him and he's a great guy. You are a good actor.
哦，我爱他。我爱他。非常好。那是……你的第二次，肖恩是怎么请到你而我没有？该死。因为我喜欢他，他是个好人。你是个好演员。
I always feel like I'm liked when I'm around you. Where are you? Are you in the basement? I'm in my lair. Okay. Lower lair. Because crime might need to be fought. Oh, God.
我总觉得我在你身边时很受欢迎。你在哪？你在地下室吗？我在我的巢穴里。好的。下层巢穴。因为可能需要打击犯罪。哦，天哪。
I am. Yes. Wait, what songs have been written about you? Dear Ben and Dear Ben Part Two. The songs that have been written about me have been written by the greatest performer in the history of the world, Jennifer Lopez. I don't know that they're exactly so much about me as maybe inspired by because, you know, because there's some negative things.
我是。是的。等等，有什么歌是关于你的？《亲爱的本》和《亲爱的本第二部》。写关于我的歌的人是世界上历史上最伟大的表演者，詹妮弗·洛佩兹。我不知道它们是否完全是关于我，也许是受到启发，因为，你知道，因为有一些负面的东西。
So they're aimed at you. I was going to say, are they flattering? She's amazing. Yes. And also, there is a third song written about me, but not by anyone gifted. Jimmy Kimmel wrote a song about me called I'm Fucking Ben Affleck. Oh, wait. Did Jennifer write the songs about you during or when you weren't dating?
所以它们是针对你的。我本来想问，它们是恭维吗？她太棒了。是的。而且，还有第三首歌是关于我的，但不是由有天赋的人写的。吉米·坎摩尔写了一首歌叫《我他妈的是本·阿弗莱克》。哦，等等。詹妮弗是在你们约会期间还是没约会时写的歌？
Jennifer, you know what, Jason? Uh-huh. You asked me these questions. I just want to know if they're thriving over and over. And I tell you, if you want to ask Jennifer about her career, if you're interested in her work, go ahead and screw your courage to this digging play and ask her. I learned a lot about her with that great documentary. I love that.
詹妮弗，你知道吗，杰森？嗯。你问我这些问题。我只是想知道它们是否一遍又一遍地蓬勃发展。我告诉你，如果你想问詹妮弗关于她的职业生涯，如果你对她的工作感兴趣，那就去问她吧。我从那部伟大的纪录片中学到了很多关于她的东西。我喜欢那个。
That was really, really cool. Wasn't that amazing? Yeah, I loved it. Everybody watched that. That was very good. I thought that was incredible. Yeah. And by the way, that's the first time.
那真的很酷。那不是很棒吗？是的，我喜欢。每个人都看了。那非常好。我觉得那太不可思议了。是的。顺便说一下，那是第一次。
I know we're going to interview you in just a second. But Jennifer Lopez, who was on Will and Grace twice or three times or whatever. Was she on Will and Grace? That's fun. And I was one, two, no times. No. You were going to meet. This is the story of my life.
我知道我们马上就要采访你了。但是詹妮弗·洛佩兹，她上过两次或三次《威尔与格蕾丝》什么的。她上过《威尔与格蕾丝》吗？那很有趣。而我上过，一，二，零次。不。你本来会见到的。这就是我的生活故事。
Will was, I wasn't. But she was, but that documentary blew me away because I was like, my God, what the woman has accomplished is astounding. Yeah. And she's not done yet. It takes a big man not to feel inadequate in the face of my wife's image. Many. But no, but she, but you too, you too, you've accomplished.
威尔上过，我没上过。但她上过，但那部纪录片让我大吃一惊，因为我想，天哪，这个女人所取得的成就是惊人的。是的。而且她还没结束。一个大男人在面对我妻子的形象时，不感到自卑是需要很大胸怀的。很多。但不，但你也是，你也是，你已经取得了。
Oh, I don't feel bad about myself. I'm not low self-esteem. I'm not, well, I'm fishing a little bit, but nothing. No, the truth is it's amazed. Sometimes I think I like completely forget because here's this incredible actress and this incredible performer. And then we're sitting in the car, you know, and I'm humming along like I will, you know, the radio.
哦，我对自己感觉不坏。我没有低自尊。我没有，好吧，我有点在钓鱼，但没什么。不，事实是这很令人惊奇。有时我想我完全忘记了，因为这里有一位不可思议的女演员和这位不可思议的表演者。然后我们坐在车里，你知道，我跟着哼唱，就像我会的那样，你知道，收音机。
And then a professional singer goes ahead and sings along and you kind of feel like, well, that's embarrassing. Yeah. You know, I should just zip it. Do you know all her music? Don't lie. I do know. Can you sing all of her songs?
然后一位专业歌手继续跟着唱，你会觉得，嗯，那很尴尬。是的。你知道，我应该闭嘴。你知道她所有的歌吗？别撒谎。我知道。你能唱她所有的歌吗？
Not to you. No, but you know them though. I can't get a J-Lo song passed to you that you haven't heard. Waiting for the night. That's the remix. There it is. That's the remix. I like when Sean kind of sounds like Cher is doing a remix.
不对你唱。不，但你知道它们。我没法给你放一首你没听过的J-Lo的歌。《Waiting for the night》。那是混音版。就是它。那是混音版。我喜欢肖恩听起来像雪儿在做混音的时候。
Waiting for the night. That was like a Cher waiting for something. I think Cross was a go. Now you're making me self-conscious like, oh gosh, if I were on like Jeopardy! Would I miss a question? But I do love her music. It's brilliant. And I know all of it.
《Waiting for the night》。那就像雪儿在等什么东西。我想Cross是去吧。现在你让我感到局促不安，就像，哦天哪，如果我在《危险边缘》上？我会错过一个问题吗？但我确实喜欢她的音乐。它很棒。而且我全都知道。
Thank you. Jason, don't put them on the fucking spot. I don't fucking like it. What the fuck? You don't even remember your wife's birthday? Yeah. I'm pretty sure that starts with an A. It is surprising.
谢谢。杰森，别把他们放在他妈的聚光灯下。我不他妈的喜欢。什么鬼？你甚至不记得你妻子的生日？是的。我很确定它是以A开头的。这确实令人惊讶。
No, wait a second. Now, Ben. Yes, hi. Hi, Ben Affleck. Like Ben Affleck's not here. Hi, Ben. It's kind of great. We don't know each other.
不，等等。现在，本。是的，嗨。嗨，本·阿弗莱克。就像本·阿弗莱克不在这里一样。嗨，本。这挺好的。我们互不相识。
Hi, thank you, somebody. Yes, hi. I don't have the pleasure of knowing you, but everybody who knows you likes you a great deal. And I feel often like Bateman. He's doing something with Bateman, which is really... Yeah, surprising. The job. Yeah, it is surprising.
嗨，谢谢，某人。是的，嗨。我没有荣幸认识你，但每个认识你的人都非常喜欢你。我经常觉得像贝特曼。他正在和贝特曼做一些事情，这真的……是的，令人惊讶。工作。是的，这令人惊讶。
It is surprising. And as you know, yes. So you, but you and Jason have known each other for a number of years? Yeah. I've known Jason a long time and had the chance to do like now four movies with a guy. I know. And by the way, the trailer for air looks incredible. It looks amazing for the new movie you guys did that you've invited Jason to be part of.
这令人惊讶。而且如你所知，是的。所以你，但你和杰森认识很多年了？是的。我认识杰森很久了，有机会和这家伙拍了四部电影。我知道。顺便说一下，Air的预告片看起来不可思议。看起来太棒了，你们拍的新电影，你们邀请了杰森参与。
And any regrets, and you can be honest now, you can be, if you have regrets about this. I got to tell you. I mean, usually, and I hate, you know, when people come on shows and they're like, you know, you're great, but what you bring, because it's just so fucking boring to listen to. But I'm going to tear it. And let me tell you why, because it's actually true. And I've lied so many times that it's nice to get the chance. Jason is fucking amazing.
还有什么遗憾吗，你现在可以诚实地说，你可以，如果你对这个有遗憾的话。我得告诉你。我的意思是，通常，我讨厌，你知道，当人们上节目时，他们就像，你知道，你很棒，但你带来的东西，因为听起来太他妈无聊了。但我会撕碎它。让我告诉你为什么，因为这是真的。我撒过太多次谎了，所以有机会说真话很好。杰森他妈的太棒了。
Guys, let him finish. And has the hardest part in the movie, which is the part where you're supposed, you know, the guy who's like, but if we don't make it to the train station by six, you know, the whole time, you know, it's constantly telling the audience what the stakes are. Look out. What's going to happen? Turn right. And somehow, like, made himself, you know, the most, I think, like the most compelling,
伙计们，让他说完。他在电影里有最难的部分，就是你被要求，你知道，那个家伙就像，但如果我们六点前不到火车站，你知道，整个过程中，你知道，不断地告诉观众赌注是什么。小心。会发生什么？向右转。而不知何故，就像，让自己，你知道，最，我认为，就像最引人注目的，
real, you're drawing. It's brilliant. I love it. A lot of it's improv and funny. And a lot of it's just humanity. But it's just brilliant. And it was such a, I was really lucky because it's, Matt did very easy. You're the lead and you're that guy and you have those lines.
真实的，你正在吸引。这很棒。我喜欢它。很多是即兴创作，很有趣。很多只是人性。但这太棒了。这真是太幸运了，因为，马特做得非常容易。你是主角，你是那个家伙，你有那些台词。
Exactly. You know what this scene is? This is me looking out the window. That's the music. You know, that's going to help. That's the wind at your back. I was the one working. Do you know, by the way, you should know, Ben, that we were at, we watched the Superbowl
没错。你知道这个场景是什么吗？这是我看着窗外。那是音乐。你知道，那会有帮助。那是你背后的风。我是那个工作的人。顺便说一下，你应该知道，本，我们在看超级碗。
at Kimmel's. Oh, yeah. I have a problem. This is a problem. And at that moment that the, that the ad for your movie came on, Jason and I were sitting there and Jimmy happened to kind of drift in right between us. And then I said, Hey, quiet everybody. Here's the, here's the, the, the commercial for the big movie.
在坎摩尔家。哦，是的。我有个问题。这是一个问题。就在那一刻，你的电影广告出现了，杰森和我坐在那里，吉米正好漂到了我们中间。然后我说，嘿，大家都安静。这是，这是，这是大电影的广告。
And Jason was all excited. And then there was just a silhouette for a second and then nothing silhouette. And then Jason's daughter goes, Dad, I thought you were in. Oh my God. In front of my kids, Ben, that can't be true. True story. Right. Jason, is that true?
杰森很兴奋。然后有一秒钟只是一个剪影，然后什么都没有，剪影。然后杰森的女儿说，爸爸，我以为你在里面。天哪。在我的孩子面前，本，那不可能是真的。真实的故事。对吧。杰森，那是真的吗？
That's a true story. There are many different commercials. I mean, it's my fault in the sense that I did see it and not notice, but, but it's not my fault. And since I didn't make it. And let me, can I talk to your daughter? This is your dad. He's very good.
那是真实的故事。有很多不同的广告。我的意思是，这是我的错，因为我确实看到了但没注意到，但，但这不是我的错。既然我没进去。我可以和你女儿谈谈吗？这是你爸爸。他很棒。
This is all a joke, but it was, it was actually pretty funny. It was like, Hey, thought you were in and everybody goes back to their chips and watching other guys. I've been there. I mean, if things aren't panning out in your career and you've been in the movie and all of a sudden you're like, I think I show up in this trade. No, the worst is when you're at the premiere and they go past the point where you know your big scene was and it's, it's now gone.
这都是个玩笑，但它，它实际上很有趣。就像，嘿，以为你在里面，然后每个人都回去吃薯片看其他人了。我经历过。我的意思是，如果事情在你的职业生涯中没有进展，你已经在电影里了，突然你就像，我想我出现在这个预告片里。不，最糟糕的是当你在首映式上，他们过了你知道你大场景的地方，现在它没了。
And they've moved on and you're like, Oh, guess that was cut. You're like, Mom, no, this is where I have the monologue. Oh, maybe it comes later now. I don't know. Maybe it's during the credits. I saved it for doing the credits. Anyway, I'll do it for you at home. It'll probably need special features.
他们继续前进了，你就像，哦，猜那被剪了。你就像，妈妈，不，这是我有独白的地方。哦，也许它现在在后面。我不知道。也许是在片尾字幕期间。我把它留到片尾字幕了。无论如何，我会回家为你表演。可能需要特别花絮。
So Ben, talk to me a little bit about, you know, we had Matt who came and joined us on, on tour, he came to Madison, Wisconsin. When you think Madison, Wisconsin, you think Matt Damon, that's the thing about Matt is he'll always do something nicer than me. Hey, what you're doing is great. You know, Matt went a whole lot further. No, no, no, no, but we did, but we talked to him about, about how you guys started and how you guys knew each other back in the day and what that was like when you guys were
所以本，跟我谈谈，你知道，我们有马特，他加入我们巡演，他去了威斯康星州麦迪逊市。当你想到威斯康星州麦迪逊市，你会想到马特·达蒙，这就是马特的事情，他总是会做一些比我更好的事情。嘿，你做的事情很棒。你知道，马特走得远多了。不，不，不，不，但我们确实，但我们和他谈过你们是怎么开始的，你们过去是怎么认识的，当你们还是……
kind of, yeah, it was really cool. Yeah, it was, it was great really hearing from him. And I, and I'd love to hear your perspective of how you guys, and I'm sure you told, told it a million times. So forgive me if it's, if it's boring, but for us, it's really, I love that story. And I told Matt, I remember we made this really bad. I say bad about my friend, but this really pretty chintzy version of a movie called Southie and you guys came to the rap party that I was in.
那种，是的，真的很酷。是的，是的，听到他的话真的很棒。而且我，我很想听听你的观点，你们是怎么，我相信你已经讲过一百万遍了。所以如果它，如果它很无聊请原谅我，但对我们来说，它真的，我喜欢那个故事。我告诉马特，我记得我们拍了这个真的很烂的。我说我朋友的坏话，但这个真的很廉价的电影叫《Southie》，你们来了我参加的杀青派对。
And then you guys were about to do Good Will Hunting. And then our movie would like, they buried it under a couch somewhere and then you guys went on to like amazing. But I just love the beginnings of what you and Matt did and I want to hear it from you because I think it's a great story. And by the way, I had no idea you guys grew up so close to each other. No idea. Yeah, we did.
然后你们正要拍《心灵捕手》。然后我们的电影就像，他们把它埋在沙发下面了，然后你们就去拍了很棒的电影。但我只是喜欢你和马特开始的样子，我想听你讲，因为我觉得这是一个伟大的故事。顺便说一下，我不知道你们从小离得那么近。不知道。是的，我们是。
First of all, it's like, it's a really lucky thing. It occurs to me now. I saw him the other day and we're doing this movie together. There's very few people are lucky enough to spend their life in the same line of work with their best friends when they were kids, managed to stay friends, not end up hating each other, actually be friends and love each other. And not have one of them soar to the stratosphere and the other one be have nothing ever happen. That was brief.
首先，这就像，这是一件非常幸运的事情。我现在想到了。我前几天见到他，我们正在一起拍这部电影。很少有人有幸能和他们小时候最好的朋友在同一行工作，设法保持朋友关系，没有最终互相憎恨，实际上是朋友并彼此相爱。而且没有让其中一个人飞向平流层，而另一个人什么都没发生。那很短暂。
But no, no, but I'm saying like, that's what usually happens. The fact that both of you guys are superstars. So in context, the reason we're asking this hacky question is because in air, the film that we're talking about, Ben, for the very, very first time, directs Matt. I love it. It's full circle. I love it. I love it.
但不，不，但我是说，就像，那通常会发生。你们俩都是超级巨星的事实。所以，在背景中，我们问这个老套问题的原因是因为在Air中，我们正在谈论的电影，本，第一次，执导马特。我喜欢它。这是圆满的。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。
Yeah, I mean, it was something that seemed really normal that I took for granted because there were, we were kids who, he was a bigger kid for a brief period. I was eight. He was 10. He was a big kid. He played baseball. He was really cool. He had a bowl cut that was feathered that we all wanted of course.
是的，我的意思是，这看起来很正常，我把它视为理所当然，因为有，我们是孩子，他，他在短暂的时间里是个更大的孩子。我八岁。他十岁。他是个大孩子。他打棒球。他真的很酷。他有一个羽毛状的碗盖头，我们当然都想要。
And he was, you know, nice to me and we were both interested in the same. Just kids who grew up two blocks apart and both wanted to be actors for whatever reason it is that makes you want to do that thing and hung out and then we're in the same friend group and then sort of went off and did like, oh, let's, you know, we're just like dumb and enough to think like, it'll pan out for us. We'll just go be actors. We'll just go work. And kind of sort of believe it and then live together.
而且他，你知道，对我很好，我们都对同样的事情感兴趣。只是两个住得只有两个街区远的孩子，出于某种原因想成为演员，想做那件事，然后一起玩，然后在同一个朋友圈里，然后就去做了，就像，哦，让我们，你知道，我们只是像笨蛋一样，认为，它会为我们成功。我们只是去当演员。我们只是去工作。而且有点相信它，然后住在一起。
But I think the reason why it wasn't a thing that sort of competition thing that you talk about is because we did a lot of auditioning very early on for the Mickey Mouse Club, for example. Amazing. I think maybe for some of Jason's early work. Gosling got the Mickey Mouse job. He did. He was one of them.
但我认为它不是那种竞争关系的原因是因为我们在很早的时候就为米老鼠俱乐部试镜了很多次，例如。太棒了。我想也许是为了杰森早期的一些工作。高斯林得到了米老鼠的工作。他确实得到了。他是其中之一。
We did a Corey Haim film called Soul Man. I remember we both auditioned for. Robin and the Clooney movie. No way. Uh-huh. Yeah. We were extras together all the time. Matt did Mystic Pizza.
我们拍了一部科里·海姆的电影叫《Soul Man》。我记得我们都试镜了。罗宾和克鲁尼的电影。没门。嗯哼。是的。我们一直在一起做临时演员。马特拍了《现代灰姑娘》。
He had a line in that. I didn't get it. And always the thing was we would get our little act together and practice our scenes and do our work. I mean, nerdy doesn't even get to describe it. Really? But it really was a genuine thing where we were like, look, I hope I get the part. But if I don't, I really hope you do.
他在里面有一句台词。我没得到。而且总是这样，我们会把我们的小表演准备好，练习我们的场景，做我们的工作。我的意思是，书呆子甚至不足以形容它。真的吗？但这确实是一件真实的事情，我们就像，看，我希望我得到这个角色。但如果我没得到，我真的希望你得到。
Right. You know, for a while we had this thing where we were like, well, just split all our money. You know what I mean? You guys have high voices. We like had, oh, you really did. Did you really say that? We really did. And we really split the money.
对。你知道，有一段时间我们有这种事，我们就像，好吧，只是平分我们所有的钱。你知道我的意思吗？你们的声音很高。我们确实有，哦，你们真的那样做了？我们真的那样做了。而且我们真的平分了钱。
No way. We put it in the bank account. At the time, I was making the lion's share of the money. Yes. No way. How old were you? Yes, Sam. We had a joint bank account.
没门。我们把它存进银行账户。当时，我赚了大部分钱。是的。没门。你多大？是的，萨姆。我们有一个联名银行账户。
I think I was 14. That was 16. Oh, that's cool. That's really awesome. We put money in the ATM. And then it's like, okay. That's so cute. What do you want to get?
我想我14岁。那是16岁。哦，那很酷。那真的很棒。我们把钱存进ATM机。然后就像，好吧。那太可爱了。你想买什么？
I saw you made a big withdrawal last weekend. Joking as much as you are. But it does show that on a certain level, there is a trust there that you guys just trust each other implicitly that there's just right. That that's on a very basic level. I like took for granted that he liked me and rooted for me and wanted me to succeed. We just didn't, we're lucky enough not to have the friendship of that the whole like it's not enough that I succeed. All my friends have to fail thing. Like, and I, there are people I've wanted to fail.
我看到你上周末取了一大笔钱。像你一样开玩笑。但这确实表明在某种程度上，有一种信任，你们只是隐式地信任对方，这只是对的。这在非常基础的层面上。我喜欢把这视为理所当然，他喜欢我，支持我，希望我成功。我们只是，我们很幸运没有那种友谊，那种整个就像，我成功是不够的。我所有的朋友都必须失败。就像，而且我，有些人我希望他们失败。
You know what I mean? I can be just as petty and bitter as any other actor, but I loved them and he loved me. And it felt like we would work the scenes together. And, you know, it actually, I think what made us sort of good writers and better actors was that we learned very early on to hear like, I'm not sure that works. That choice, you know, and you go, okay, let's try something else, you know, and get our facts, our sides. Let's try a lower voice. Do you ever give that note? That too.
你知道我的意思吗？我可以像任何其他演员一样小气和痛苦，但我爱他们，他也爱我。感觉就像我们会一起研究场景。而且，你知道，它实际上，我认为是什么让我们成为那种好的编剧和更好的演员，是因为我们很早就学会了听，就像，我不确定那行不通。那个选择，你知道，然后你说，好吧，让我们尝试别的东西，你知道，得到我们的事实，我们的侧面。让我们尝试更低的声音。你给过那个建议吗？那个也。
I had to hit puberty. So wait, but you, but when you say you grew up, you grew up. Together in Boston, right? But you were born or raised in California? Like what's the California? I was born in California. My parents were at a teaching at a like an experimental school outside Berkeley briefly. And then actually my mom, and yes.
我不得不经历青春期。所以等等，但你，但当你说是你长大的，你长大了。在波士顿一起，对吧？但你是在加州出生或长大的？加州是什么？我出生在加州。我的父母在伯克利外的一所实验学校教书，短暂地。然后实际上我妈妈，是的。
And then I moved back to Boston around two or three. I moved into a central square in Cambridge. And then Matt moved there from Newton when I was eight and he was 10. And that's when you met at the Bay at the basketball. And you got a Burger King commercial. That was your very first thing. Listen, I had done a Burger King commercial. Okay.
然后我在两三岁左右搬回了波士顿。我搬进了剑桥的中央广场。然后马特在我八岁他十岁时从牛顿搬到那里。那就是你们在篮球场见面的时候。而且你得到了一个汉堡王的广告。那是你的第一件事。听着，我拍过一个汉堡王的广告。好的。
I'm sure you remember the slogan was sometimes you got to break the rules. Oh yeah. A little bit of a rule breaker. Really quick. I did it. I did it. These guys are gonna love this. I did a McDonald's commercial.
我相信你记得口号是“有时你必须打破规则”。哦，是的。有点规则破坏者。真的很快。我做了。我做了。这些家伙会喜欢这个的。我拍了一个麦当劳的广告。
One of my first things where I worried, I worried about how I was going to impress a girl. And the catchphrase from my guy scene partner was, don't worry about it. I was like, how am I going to pay for the date? Don't worry about it. That's my story. So wait. Go back to the burger. Holy shit.
我最早的事情之一，我担心，我担心我该如何给一个女孩留下深刻印象。而我的场景搭档的口头禅是，别担心。我当时想，我该怎么付约会的钱？别担心。那是我的故事。所以等等。回到汉堡。该死。
You're going to get hired one day. Ben's got a head of steam going. You're going to be out of the job. There's so much movement. You'll be out of podcasts. One of these days. Out of gas. Jesus.
你总有一天会被雇用的。本的势头很猛。你会失业的。有太多的动作。你会没播客可做的。总有一天。没油了。天哪。
You're fucking... Sorry, go ahead, Ben. Anyway, let me just... Can I regroup? Do you mind? Oh man, take all the time. Just go ahead and start over. Shake it off.
你他妈的……抱歉，继续，本。无论如何，让我只是……我可以重组一下吗？你介意吗？哦伙计，花所有时间。继续重新开始。甩掉它。
And then you think he's crying. So we were... I've established that we were very nerdy and a little weird. We used to have business lunches in what was called the Media Cafeteria. Amazing. Which at the time, there was a big ESL portion of our public high school, which was like 2600 kids, and that was where the ESL kids... I don't know why that was where we...
然后你以为他在哭。所以我们是……我已经确定我们非常书呆子气，有点奇怪。我们过去常在所谓的媒体自助餐厅吃商务午餐。太棒了。当时，我们公立高中有很大一部分ESL学生，大概有2600个孩子，那就是ESL孩子……我不知道为什么那是我们……
We liked to be surrounded by people who spoke other languages. I'm not sure what it was, but maybe we didn't want them to actually hear our business lunches. Sure. Because no business was conducted. Yeah. But we plotted things. We planned our careers. But look at you now.
我们喜欢被说其他语言的人包围。我不确定那是什么，但也许我们不想让他们真的听到我们的商务午餐。当然。因为没有进行任何业务。是的。但我们策划了事情。我们计划了我们的职业生涯。但看看现在的你。
Look at the business you guys are in now. Artist equity, yes? Yeah. Yeah. It is bizarre to have gone this far. And definitely a lot of... I don't think I would be as sane to the extent that I am had I not had somebody who was from where I grew up and who was my best friend and who was going through the same thing.
看看你们现在从事的业务。艺术家权益，对吧？是的。是的。走到这一步真是离奇。而且绝对有很多……我不认为我会像现在这样理智，如果我没有一个来自我成长的地方，而且是我最好的朋友，并且正在经历同样事情的人。
So you could... Because I'm sure you guys all know there are these moments in this business where you look around and go like, is this completely insane? Yeah. Every day. Absolutely. I feel as though, you know, I'm coming unglued. And having that when somebody shared that perspective.
所以你可以……因为我相信你们都知道在这个行业里有这些时刻，你环顾四周，就像，这完全疯了吗？是的。绝对。我觉得，你知道，我正在解体。而且当有人分享那种观点时。
And then so as we went on and on, so finally got to a place where, like with Last Duel, it was like, why haven't we just... We had so much fun every day on that set. It was so much fun. And we were just like, let's just do this. Let's just do movies together and with people we like. And we will be right back. SmartLess is in part brought to you by Nerd Wallet.
然后随着我们继续下去，所以终于到了一个地方，就像《最后的决斗》，就像，为什么我们还没有……我们在那个片场每天都玩得很开心。太有趣了。我们只是就像，让我们这样做吧。让我们一起拍电影，和我们喜欢的人一起。我们马上回来。SmartLess部分由Nerd Wallet赞助。
SmartLess listeners, you like to listen to us even though you understand that we are not that smart. Talented and handsome, sure. But smart is not one of our strong suits. That's where our sponsor comes in. Nerd Wallet, where you can compare top financial products side by side and make smart financial decisions. Nerd Wallet has a whole team of nerds who help you make smart decisions on your next credit card, high yield savings account, and more. And these aren't people who just say they're smart.
SmartLess听众，你们喜欢听我们说话，即使你们明白我们并不那么聪明。有才华和英俊，当然。但聪明不是我们的强项。这就是我们的赞助商进来的地方。Nerd Wallet，你可以在那里并排比较顶级金融产品，做出明智的财务决策。Nerd Wallet有一整队书呆子，帮助你在下一张信用卡、高收益储蓄账户等方面做出明智的决定。而且这些人不仅仅是说他们聪明。
They're like actually smart. They've got CFPs, MBAs, years of experience, and they're using their expertise to offer side by side comparisons and objective ratings on top financial products for you. Are you spending more on gas or groceries lately? Of course you are. The world is terrible. Turn that negative into a positive gang and find a cashback card that rewards you for what you spend the most on. All right.
他们是真正聪明。他们有CFP、MBA、多年的经验，他们正在利用他们的专业知识为你提供顶级金融产品的并排比较和客观评级。你最近在汽油或杂货上花得更多了吗？当然你是。世界很糟糕。把那个消极变成积极，伙计们，找到一张奖励你消费最多的现金返还卡。好的。
Now that sounds like pretty smart stuff to me. That's coming from a guy who's not that smart, but boy, I can sniff. I can sniff smart. I can smell it. Okay. And this stinks like smart stuff. So listeners, it's time to stop being smartless and time to get smart with the nerds at Nerd Wallet. Compare and find top cashback credit cards, savings accounts, and more at nerdwallet.com.
现在这听起来对我来说很聪明。这是一个不太聪明的人说的，但天哪，我可以闻到。我可以闻到聪明。我可以闻到它。好的。而且这闻起来像聪明的东西。所以听众们，是时候停止无脑，是时候和Nerd Wallet的书呆子们一起变聪明了。在nerdwallet.com比较并找到顶级现金返还信用卡、储蓄账户等。
Nerd Wallet, the smartest decision for all your financial decisions. Not sure if you guys know this, but smart list is brought to you in part by BetterHelp. Getting to know yourself can be a lifelong process, especially because we're always growing and changing. Now, I change all the time. I mean, just my nose hair and ear hair alone is changing at a rapid rate. Okay. Not to mention what's going on inside my melon, right? All kinds of stuff going on upstairs.
Nerd Wallet，为你所有财务决策做出的最明智的决定。不确定你们是否知道这一点，但SmartLess部分由BetterHelp赞助。了解自己可能是一个终生的过程，特别是当我们一直在成长和变化时。现在，我一直在变。我的意思是，光是我的鼻毛和耳毛就在以极快的速度变化。好的。更不用说我脑袋里发生了什么，对吧？楼上发生了各种各样的事情。
But anyway, therapy is all about deepening your self-awareness and understanding because sometimes we don't know what we want or why we react the way we do until we talk through things, right? BetterHelp connects you with a licensed therapist who can take you on that journey of self-discovery from wherever you are. Now, I have benefited greatly by talking to people who are much smarter than myself, which is most of the planet. What BetterHelp is great at is it just puts it right at your fingertips. You don't have to get in your car and drive down to, you know, some doctor's office and sit in the lobby and wait to go in and chit chat and then you've got to drive home. It's just, it's right there.
但无论如何，治疗就是关于加深你的自我意识和理解，因为有时我们不知道我们想要什么，或者为什么我们会有这样的反应，直到我们谈论事情，对吧？BetterHelp为你联系一位持证治疗师，无论你在哪里，都能带你踏上自我发现的旅程。现在，我从与比我聪明得多的人交谈中受益匪浅，也就是地球上的大多数人。BetterHelp很棒的地方在于它把它放在你的指尖。你不必开车去，你知道，某个医生的办公室，坐在大厅里等着进去聊天，然后你还得开车回家。它就在那里。
You want to talk? Boom. You get it done. Now, if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online. It's designed to be convenient. It's flexible. It's suited to your schedule.
你想谈谈吗？砰。你完成了。现在，如果你正在考虑开始治疗，给BetterHelp一个机会。它完全在线。它设计得很方便。它很灵活。它适合你的日程安排。
All you got to do is just fill out a brief questionnaire, get matched with a licensed therapist, and switch therapists at any time if you want for no additional charge. Discover your potential with BetterHelp. See, you don't necessarily need to be fixing a problem. You might just want to maybe just kind of see if you're getting all you can get out of yourself, you know, and these people can help you check that out. So, discover your potential with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today. Get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp.
你所要做的就是填写一份简短的问卷，与一位持证治疗师匹配，如果你愿意，可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。用BetterHelp发现你的潜力。看，你不一定需要解决一个问题。你可能只是想看看你是否从自己身上得到了你能得到的一切，你知道，这些人可以帮助你检查一下。所以，用BetterHelp发现你的潜力。今天访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartlist。在你的第一个月获得10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp。
H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlist. Ah, que bella, smartlist listener. It's brought to you in part by Viori. Ah, not tired of sacrificing style for comfort or vice versa. This is a little Slavic, but I want you to bear with me. Look no further than Viori. The performance clothing brand that combines both. Viori offers the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet, making it perfect investment in your happiness, huh?
H-E-L-P点com斜杠smartlist。啊，多美啊，SmartLess听众。它部分由Viori赞助。啊，不厌倦为了舒适而牺牲风格，反之亦然。这有点斯拉夫语，但我希望你和我一起忍受。看看Viori就知道了。结合两者的性能服装品牌。Viori提供地球上最舒适和多功能的服装，让你对幸福的投资变得完美，嗯？
From joggers to leggings to crew necks. Viori is everything you need to be comfy, stylish, no matter what you're doing. Now, I walked into Viori the other day just to take a little look-see at one of their new shops over here near my house. And boy, was I pleasantly surprised with what they had in there was the new spring stuff, okay? Last time I went in there was a winter stuff. And I just, I lit up. I spent a little bit more than I wanted to. So I got a little bit of a bill to pay with mommy here back at home.
从慢跑裤到紧身裤再到圆领衫。Viori是你需要舒适、时尚的一切，无论你在做什么。现在，我前几天走进Viori，只是想看看我家附近他们的一家新店。天哪，我很高兴地发现他们里面有新的春季商品，好的？上次我去那里是冬季商品。我只是，我亮了起来。我花得比我想的多了一点。所以我得和家里的妈妈付点账单。
But you know what? You know what's offsetting that? The handsomeness that I'm wearing when I talk to her about the extra money that I spent. So she's good. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase, right? Do I have your attention? Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at viori.com slash smartlist. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartlist.
但你知道吗？你知道什么在抵消那个吗？当我跟她谈论我多花的钱时，我穿着的英俊。所以她很好。对于我们的听众，他们提供你第一次购买20%的折扣，对吧？我有你的注意了吗？在viori.com斜杠smartlist上给自己买一些地球上最舒适和多功能的服装。那是V-U-O-R-I点com斜杠smartlist。
Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. order. There's over $75 and free returns. Go to viori.com slash smartlist and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. I'm never going to get hired to play anybody but a dumbass American. And now back to the show. Going back to the first thing that kind of launched was it dazed and confused? Or was it something before that? And what's the story about Vince Vaughn?
你不仅会收到第一次购买20%的折扣，而且你还会享受任何美国订单的免费送货。超过75美元和免费退货。去viori.com斜杠smartlist，发现Viori服装的多功能性。我永远不会被雇佣去扮演除了笨蛋美国人以外的任何人。现在回到节目。回到启动的那第一件事，是《年少轻狂》吗？还是在那之前的东西？关于文斯·沃恩的故事是什么？
He's asked a two-parter there. You can take him one at a time or you can ask him to repeat it. I get excited. I get excited. I know it. I know it. Do you ever write these things down? Pre-interview the Vince bit.
他问了一个两部分的问题。你可以一次回答一个，或者你可以要求他重复一遍。我很兴奋。我很兴奋。我知道。我知道。你有没有把这些东西写下来？文斯片段的预采访。
I don't know where you're going with that. I do know that I had done a couple of what I was the more experienced. I don't want to make Matt feel insecure. I had some early experience with professional acting. You're selling burgers. Well, not only I sell burgers, but I don't know if you know your public television history. I was on a show. Voyage of the Mimi.
我不知道你要去哪里。我确实知道我做过几个，我是更有经验的。我不想让马特感到不安全。我有一些早期的专业表演经验。你在卖汉堡。好吧，我不只是卖汉堡，但我不知道你是否了解你的公共电视历史。我上过一个节目。《Mimi的航行》。
No, Voyage of the Mimi. Science, it was also shown to sixth graders for their science class because I think because it was so gripping. And a young boy and his grandpa wrenching out a boat to scientists for experiments. And so I would periodically go off into a little Voyage of the Mimi. So Matt was a little threatened by that. And when I got to the high school, he kind of pulled me aside. And he said, listen, man, all right, this is the theater. It's not about your looks.
不，是《Mimi号航行记》。科学，它也曾在六年级科学课上播放，因为我觉得它太引人入胜了。一个小男孩和他的爷爷把一艘船租给科学家做实验。所以我偶尔会沉浸在《Mimi号航行记》的小世界里。马特对此感到有点威胁。当我上高中时，他把我拉到一边。他说，听着，伙计，好了，这是戏剧。这不是关于你的长相。
It's about the work. And I took that very seriously. I felt that I was hearing something, you know, real like the words of wisdom from a guy who understood it. I didn't know until that time he felt I'd been entirely bow guarding my way through life on like charming looks of which there were very few. Well, no, it sounds like actually you came roaring into high school just killing it. Yeah, you were crushing it. And Matt and Matt, I mean, by the way, I mean, again, no insult to Matt, but it sounds like he felt threatened by you, Ben.
这是关于作品本身。我非常认真地对待了这一点。我觉得我听到了一些东西，你知道，就像一个真正懂行的人给出的智慧之言。在那之前我不知道他觉得我一直是在靠那点微不足道的魅力在生活中混日子。好吧，不，听起来你其实在高中时表现得非常出色。是的，你当时表现得太棒了。而且马特，我的意思是，顺便说一句，我不是在侮辱马特，但听起来他确实感到被你威胁了，本。
And I want to just... I think maybe... I think maybe it's a little... I'm gonna show this on the guy. The other thing he said to me was like, you know the thing about Hoffman and Salesman is you can see the wheels turning, but he wants you to see the wheels turning. That day I'm 15 years old, Matt. No way.
我想……我觉得也许……我觉得也许有点……我要在那个家伙面前展示一下。他对我说的另一件事是，你知道关于霍夫曼和《推销员之死》的事情是，你可以看到他大脑在飞速运转，但他希望你看到他在思考。那天我15岁，马特。没门。
That's hysterical. That's a true story. That's fucking amazing. However, that's why he's brilliant because that guy has been absolutely convinced that and has paid attention to like, you know, very little else in his free time other than acting since he was a little kid doing Wheelock Community College Theater when he was 11 years old. And he's been with absolute conviction that this is what he was going to do. And he was a lot smarter about it than me. He understood a lot earlier on.
太搞笑了。那是真实的故事。这太他妈神奇了。然而，这就是他为什么才华横溢的原因，因为那家伙从11岁在威洛克社区学院演戏开始，就一直坚信这一点，并且在业余时间几乎没有关注过演戏以外的任何事情。他一直坚信这就是他要做的事情。而且他在这方面比我聪明得多。他很早就明白了。
He was like, it's just all about the director. I'm just gonna focus on the director. He was like passing on parts when we were broke. I said, what are you passing on? You can't pay the gas bill. How is this not good enough for you? Because he didn't like the director? Yeah, he just didn't feel he didn't have anything to offer.
他就像是，一切都取决于导演。我只会专注于导演。我们穷困潦倒时，他还在推掉一些角色。我说，你在推掉什么？你连煤气费都付不起。这怎么就不能满足你了？因为他不喜欢那个导演？是的，他只是觉得他没什么可发挥的。
You know? Wow. I was like, I'm doing after school specials about steroid abuse. You're passing on like movies. That's pretty great. But I will say this, you gave him a piece of advice that he has since paid for and given and he let us in on it last year when he came to join us, which was apparently you said to him, if somebody asks you to do something down the road, imagine that the same, you know, get it all the time. Hey, will you come and do this six months from now and come to show up at this thing?
你知道吗？哇。我当时在拍关于类固醇滥用的课后特别节目。你却在推掉电影。那太棒了。但我得说，你给了他一个建议，他后来为此付出了代价，也从中受益，去年他来参加我们的节目时告诉了我们，显然你对他说，如果有人让你在未来做某事，想象一下……你总是会遇到这种情况。嘿，你愿意六个月后做这个，并出现在这个活动上吗？
Imagine that you would have to do it tomorrow and then let that be your answer. Yeah. If you don't want to do it tomorrow, say no. I did give him that. I never thought that was particularly wise. I just thought, no, it's because that was constantly saying yes and then be like, hey man, can you call them and tell them I'm sick? Right. And that's bullshit.
想象一下你明天就得做这件事，然后让那成为你的答案。是的。如果你明天不想做，就说不。我确实给了他那个建议。我从来没觉得那特别聪明。我只是觉得，不，是因为我总是说好，然后又说，嘿伙计，你能打电话告诉他们我病了吗？对。那简直是胡扯。
I've told minimum 50 people that piece of advice as if I came up with it my own and they have people love it and have latched onto it. Right, JB? We've talked about it all the time. I live it. I did it today. I do something like three months from now that sounds kind of interesting. I'll be kind of fun. But then I thought, well, actually, if it was on the calendar for tomorrow, would I wish that it was canceled?
我已经把那个建议告诉了至少50个人，就好像是我自己想出来的一样，他们都很喜欢，并且采纳了。对吧，JB？我们一直在谈论它。我践行着它。我今天就这么做了。我三个月后要做点什么，听起来还挺有趣的。但后来我想，好吧，如果明天日程表上就有这件事，我希望它被取消吗？
If the answer is yes, pass. I love that. You know, the thing about that that I can't completely co-sign, like my dirty little secret is, I might pass on everything. Did you think about that? Like, I almost never want to get off the couch. Did you think about this show today, about passing on this show? Oh, I mean, I was half dollar late, wasn't I? Yeah.
如果答案是肯定的，那就拒绝。我喜欢这个。你知道，关于这一点我不能完全认同的是，我那不可告人的小秘密是，我可能会拒绝所有事情。你想过吗？就像我几乎从来不想离开沙发。你今天考虑过这个节目吗，关于拒绝这个节目？哦，我的意思是，我迟到了半个多小时，不是吗？是的。
They had to talk you out of it. So for the guy who likes to do nothing except sit on his couch every day like I do, I find it interesting that you're actually able to get up and work as hard as I think anybody could possibly work when it comes to directing. Like, that's a really, really all-encompassing job. So are you like me where it's like either all or nothing? I'm either working full or out. I think you and I have that in common, yes. And I think that part of it is, it's a little bit like, it's more sort of social things. Like, I feel actually kind of shy.
他们不得不说服你参加。所以对于像我一样每天除了坐在沙发上什么都不想做的人来说，我觉得你能站起来工作，而且在导演方面工作得如此努力，这很有趣。那真的是一份非常全面的工作。所以你和我一样是那种要么全做要么不做的人吗？我要么全力以赴，要么完全不做。我想你和我在这点上很像，是的。而且我认为部分原因是，这更像是一种社交方面的问题。比如，我其实觉得有点害羞。
I don't really want to go say hi to people. I feel a little bit like, oh, I'm going to, you know, something's going to happen. This is going to make me feel awkward. But I love directing movies. And that movie in particular was the best experience I've had. And directing is hard and terrifying and at first I thought like, okay, even if I don't know anything about this, I know that I can at least work harder than everybody else. And so I thought, well, you put in 20 hours a day and that's what you do. And it made it excruciating and I got migraines.
我真的不想去和人打招呼。我有点觉得，哦，我要，你知道，会发生什么事。这会让我感到尴尬。但我喜欢导演电影。那部电影尤其是我有过的最好的经历。导演工作既艰难又可怕，起初我想，好吧，即使我对这方面一无所知，我知道我至少可以比其他人工作得更努力。所以我心想，好吧，你每天投入20个小时，这就是你要做的。这让过程变得极其痛苦，我还得了偏头痛。
But like to the extent that the movies, you know, I was happy with, I thought, well, it must be because I worked 20 hours a day and did nothing else and thought of nothing else. And eventually realized that you don't quite have to do it that way. And that actually this movie, which is the favorite movie I've ever made, I love this movie. It benefits entirely from the writing and acting of Jason and Matt and Chris and Viola and Christina and Matt Mayer. But it was so much fucking fun every day. Well, it's your fault. I mean, well, we don't have to do a whole thing on the kind of set you run and your talent and everything. But it was...
但就我满意的电影而言，我想，好吧，那一定是因为我每天工作20个小时，什么都不做，什么都不想。最终意识到你并不完全需要那样做。而且实际上这部电影，这是我拍过的最喜欢的电影，我爱这部电影。它完全得益于杰森、马特、克里斯、维奥拉、克里斯蒂娜和马特·梅耶的剧本和表演。但每天都他妈太有趣了。好吧，这是你的错。我的意思是，好吧，我们不必大谈特谈你管理的片场和你的才华等等。但它……
No, no, no. We can actually... Actually, I don't understand. We have 25 to 30. It was actually incredibly easy. Guys, we shot this down the street. We shot it in a business in an office building that you were supposed to be in an office building. So they basically just flipped the lights on.
不，不，不。我们其实可以……其实，我不明白。我们有25到30天。这实际上非常容易。伙计们，我们就在街对面拍的。我们在一个办公大楼里拍的，你本来就应该在办公大楼里。所以他们基本上只是打开了灯。
Now, that's to take nothing away from Bob Richardson, who is like the best DP in the history of movies. But it was very fast. I think after... Wasn't it after like seven days we were already three days ahead? Yeah. Something like that? I wanted to go quickly and then you and Matt showed up. And like having not directed Matt, I didn't appreciate that.
现在，这并不是要贬低鲍勃·理查森，他是电影史上最好的摄影指导。但速度非常快。我想在……七天之后我们不是已经提前了三天吗？是的。差不多吧？我想快速完成，然后你和马特出现了。而且作为导演没导过马特，我没意识到这一点。
When you're a director, right, you have your plans. You're worrying about all these other things. Yes, you're worrying about the performances. But I thought, okay, well, I won't have to worry about the performances. And I'll just worry about all the other sort of bullshit I'm doing that I think is relevant when really the actors are the only thing the audience is paying attention to. And like, you know, camera moves and that kind of thing. And Jason and Matt are such pros that I mean, it was like a dance to watch these two guys together. They've done it so much and so well.
当你是一名导演时，对吧，你有你的计划。你在担心所有其他事情。是的，你在担心表演。但我心想，好吧，我不用担心表演。我只会担心我正在做的所有其他那些我认为相关的废话，而实际上演员才是观众唯一关注的东西。比如，你知道，摄像机移动之类的。杰森和马特是如此专业，我的意思是，看着这两个家伙在一起就像一场舞蹈。他们做过太多次了，而且做得非常好。
So that as soon as you start to feel the dolly is laid, it's not going to be all of a sudden Jason's looking in his pocket for something that might be behind him. And that looks bad. And all of a sudden he makes maybe a little more mournful choice on that line delivery because it's going to give him an extra half step to the turn to where he knows the steady cam is going to come. The two of the guys... Yeah, yeah, yeah. And I started feeling like you're making it for me. That part is so fun. I love that.
所以当你开始感觉到轨道车铺设好时，杰森不会突然在口袋里找可能在他身后的东西。那看起来很糟糕。突然间，他在那句台词上做出了一个更忧伤的选择，因为这会让他多走半步，转到他知道斯坦尼康会来的地方。这两个家伙……是啊，是啊，是啊。我开始觉得你们是在为我制作这部电影。那部分太有趣了。我喜欢那个。
It really was amazing to see. In fact, it got to the point where because Bob's crew and everyone was so good, they started anticipating and trying to do it. And then the guys who were really good and women who were doing it were like, it started to just speed up. And finally I was like, Matt, Jason, don't do their job for them. You don't have to do everybody's job. Yes, I know you're great at it. But just worry about the scene because I think they kind of started having fun with it. Because I had wonters and you'd have to see this and that and Jason would know.
看到这一幕真的很神奇。事实上，到了后来，因为鲍勃的团队和每个人都太棒了，他们开始预判并尝试去做。然后那些真正优秀的男男女女就开始了，速度开始加快。最后我说，马特，杰森，别替他们做他们的工作。你们不必做每个人的工作。是的，我知道你们很擅长。但只要担心场景就行了，因为我觉得他们开始从中找到乐趣了。因为我有要求，你得看这个那个，杰森就会知道。
You're probably going to want that magenta in the background. And I thought you'd like the window and I was like, you son of a bitch. Yeah, I did want the window. I didn't think I was that transparent. Can you remember having any sort of significant creative negotiation with Matt, either in the writing process or in the directing process? Like giving him a note that he didn't want to take or writing a scene that he thought was kind of fine already? Because didn't you have the writing process like Goodwill Huntingham back in college where you would... Well, they won an Oscar.
你可能想要背景里的那种洋红色。我以为你会喜欢那个窗户，我就说，你这个混蛋。是的，我确实想要那个窗户。我没想到我那么透明。你还记得和马特有过任何重大的创意协商吗，无论是在写作过程中还是在导演过程中？比如给他一个他不想接受的建议，或者写了一个他觉得已经很完美的场景？因为你们在大学里写《心灵捕手》的时候不是有写作过程吗，你们会……好吧，他们赢得了奥斯卡。
You would talk about it or improv it and record it? We recorded it, yeah. On what were audio cassettes at the time. Kids, those were small, brown, deep cassettes. Really put in devices. Wait, really? You guys talked out the script? Yeah, because we never thought of ourselves as formal writers.
你们会讨论它或者即兴创作并录下来？我们录下来了，是的。在当时是音频磁带上。孩子们，那是小小的、棕色的、深色的磁带。真的放进设备里。等等，真的吗？你们讨论出了剧本？是的，因为我们从没把自己看作正式的编剧。
We had a great teacher, a drama teacher in high school who taught us kind of sort of writing, directing, acting and didn't sort of put them in distinct silos. So he was, we would actually end up making plays, which we later, I later realized we were act, write, direct them in effect. But we just thought we would improvise them and kind of distill them down and find a story. Such a great idea. So that's just how we know how to do it. This person did you such a favor by doing that, by sort of putting it all together, right? There's no question without Jerry Speck and Matt, or I, or my brother, or Matt Mayer, or Max Casala, or Nico Larsen, or all the people that came out of the program who are working and who are terrific would, I think, be working. Because he was, he taught us that and he taught us to like, to not take ourselves seriously, respect other people, but take the work that we were doing incredibly seriously.
我们有一位很棒的老师，高中时的戏剧老师，他教我们写作、导演、表演，并没有把它们放在不同的领域里。所以他，我们最终会制作戏剧，后来我意识到我们实际上是在表演、写作、导演它们。但我们只是认为我们会即兴创作，把它们提炼出来，找到一个故事。真是个好主意。所以这就是我们知道怎么做的方法。这个人通过这样做帮了你们大忙，把这一切整合在一起，对吧？毫无疑问，如果没有杰里·斯佩克，马特，或者我，或者我兄弟，或者马特·梅耶，或者马克斯·卡萨拉，或者尼科·拉森，或者所有从那个项目中出来并正在工作且非常出色的人，我想，他们可能就不会在工作了。因为他，他教了我们这些，他教我们不要把自己看得太重，尊重他人，但要极其认真地对待我们正在做的工作。
And that was like that kind of, and there's that like great time of life when you have the older person as the mentor who you look up to in the, who's doing the thing you want to do, who says, this is meaningful, but you really have to work hard at it. And so we did. Ben, is that, that's it. So that was a teacher that you guys had at your public high school. I went to. I mean, our public high school just lucked out and got this guy who's a genius. That's amazing. And he was amazing for kids that didn't even end up wanting to be in theater and he was, I could do a whole thing on him.
那就像那种，人生中有一段美好的时光，当你有一位你仰慕的长辈作为导师，他在做你想做的事情，他说，这很有意义，但你真的必须为此努力工作。所以我们做了。本，就是这样。所以那是你们在公立高中遇到的老师。我去了。我的意思是，我们的公立高中很幸运，遇到了这个天才。这太神奇了。对于那些甚至最终不想从事戏剧的孩子来说，他也很棒，他，我可以为他做一整期节目。
But the truth is, I think that's part of why I learned to be collaborative is that Matt and I never fought or argued about stuff. It was always that we, and we never got our feelings hurt because most of the ideas are bad. So I'll have a bad idea. He'll have a bad idea. I'll have a bad idea. He'll have a bad idea. I'll have an idea what that's a little bit that may be better. And then Matt, that kind of key something in math that's mediocre, you know what I mean?
但事实是，我认为这就是我学会合作的部分原因，马特和我从来没有为事情争吵过。总是我们，而且我们从来没有伤害过彼此的感情，因为大多数想法都很糟糕。所以我会有个坏主意。他会有个坏主意。我会有个坏主意。他会有个坏主意。我会有一个稍微好一点的想法。然后马特，那种在数学中平庸的东西，你知道我的意思吗？
So we know we're building from there and it's never about, and then it just becomes about like finding the best thing until both of us feel like it can't be improved. And, and we kind of go like, and, and if there is a kind of difference of opinion, it always ends up coming down to who cares more. Yeah, I don't know. I really think this is about the, and he's like, man, that and I go, all right. Yeah, if you don't want to do it more than I want to do it, then we're not going to do it, you know? Or if I want to do it more than you don't want to do it, we're going to do it. Like that's just common. Amanda and I try to live by that.
所以我们知道我们是从那里建立起来的，这从来不是关于，然后它就变成了寻找最好的东西，直到我们俩都觉得它无法再改进了。然后，我们有点像，而且，如果有一种意见分歧，它总是归结为谁更在乎。是的，我不知道。我真的认为这是关于，他说，伙计，那个，我说，好吧。是的，如果你不想做它胜过我想做它，那我们就不会做，你知道吗？或者如果我想做它胜过你不想做它，我们就会做。这很常见。阿曼达和我试着那样生活。
There she is. Oh, look, it's Jennifer, a special guest. There she is. Hi. You can't hear us. Hi. Hi, Jen. Hi.
她在那儿。哦，看，是詹妮弗，特别嘉宾。她在那儿。嗨。你听不到我们说话。嗨。嗨，珍。嗨。
Hi, guys. You were just doing very well. We were talking about you in very favorable terms and so was your husband. Oh, thank you. I was singing some of your songs back to you. Sing, please sing. We're waiting for the night. Oh.
嗨，伙计们。你们刚才做得很好。我们正在以非常赞赏的口吻谈论你，你丈夫也是。哦，谢谢。我刚才在给你们唱你们的一些歌。唱吧，请唱。我们在等那个夜晚。哦。
Oh, my love. It's waiting for two nights. Waiting for two nights. Oh, that's the mic drop right there. But thank you. She crushed it. That's when we're lucky that we're back. That is brilliant.
哦，我的爱。是在等两个夜晚。等两个夜晚。哦，那真是麦克风掉落的时刻。但谢谢。她表现得太棒了。那是我们幸运的时候，我们回来了。那太精彩了。
Thank you for saying hi. Yes, of course. Bye, Jennifer. She's looking forward to doing this with you guys. Oh, good. I love you. Hello, guys. I'm Scott DeRion.
谢谢你打招呼。是的，当然。再见，詹妮弗。她很期待和你们一起做这个。哦，好。我爱你。你们好，伙计们。我是斯科特·德里昂。
Hello, guys. I'm Scott. And I'm one of the guys that will make the show. By the way, we just bypass Jason's. I didn't know this term. Creative negotiation. Yeah. Wait.
你们好，伙计们。我是斯科特。我是制作这个节目的人之一。顺便说一句，我们刚刚绕过了杰森的。我不知道这个词。创意协商。是的。等等。
Way to take the yard out of it, man. You fucking find a way every fucking time. Business. My friend. Game. How much for the. Batteries. Hey Picasso.
把院子从里面拿出来的方式，伙计。你每次都他妈能找到办法。生意。我的朋友。游戏。多少钱。电池。嘿，毕加索。
How much painted you use? How many cubic liters of painted you use? That's the fucking art. Picasso had never had to negotiate with anybody because it's just a single thing. Well, what we're doing is like team stuff, right? So you gotta always negotiate. It is a lot of negotiations.
你用了多少颜料？你用了多少立方升的颜料？那才是他妈的艺术。毕加索从来不需要和任何人协商，因为那只是一件单一的事情。好吧，我们做的是团队合作，对吧？所以你总是得协商。这确实有很多协商。
I mean, the lucky thing is when you don't have to negotiate, when you go like, you know, you do something, you write it, you give it to him, and then Jason sits down and reads the scene, and like, he made me cry on this. And then you feel like a jerk because you feel like that guy who just like, was it Marty Short or whatever, who's to go?
我的意思是，幸运的是当你不需要协商时，当你去，你知道，你做某事，你写下来，你把它给他，然后杰森坐下来读那个场景，就像，他让我在这上面哭了。然后你觉得自己像个混蛋，因为你觉得像那个家伙，是马蒂·肖特还是什么人，谁总是去？
And then, oh, you know, you just wanna get one of those. What was the name of that character you played? Jiminy Glick. Jiminy Glick, I just watched him last night. I have a question. Mr. Affleck. Damn. Ruff, ruff, ruff.
然后，哦，你知道，你只是想得到其中一个。你演的那个角色叫什么名字？吉米尼·格里克。吉米尼·格里克，我昨晚刚看了他。我有个问题。阿弗莱克先生。该死。汪，汪，汪。
And then he goes, don't. So to wrap up the Matt stuff, we'll leave him out of the rest of the interview. But the, because we've had enough of Matt, right? I mean, Will, with you, with your wordle, quartile, and squirtle every morning. I wanna get in on that. And Matt was like, you're not ready.
然后他说，别。所以为了结束马特的事情，我们会在采访的其余部分把他排除在外。但是，因为我们已经受够了马特了，对吧？我的意思是，威尔，和你，每天早上你的Wordle，Quartle和Squirtle。我想加入那个。马特说，你还没准备好。
I was like, we're not ready. Jason dropped out, he couldn't take the heat. No, it's not the heat. It's Will likes to tell you how much better his score could have been had he done X, Y, or Z. Anyway, this really, but. Wait, wait, I wanted to close the Matt part of it.
我说，我们还没准备好。杰森退出了，他受不了压力。不，不是压力。是威尔喜欢告诉你，如果他做了X、Y或Z，他的分数会好多少。总之，这真的，但是。等等，等等，我想结束马特的那部分。
Tell for the, and you could, I know I would love to do a full podcast with you about artist equity and all the studio economics that you're embodying. They didn't tell me you didn't wanna do this one. We put our audience to sleep. So for those that have narcolepsy, do the quick version of generally what the concept is,
告诉，你可以，我知道我很乐意和你做一个完整的播客，关于艺术家权益和你正在体现的所有工作室经济学。他们没告诉我你不想做这个。我们让我们的观众睡着了。所以对于那些患有嗜睡症的人，简要说明一下这个概念是什么，
what you guys are doing versus what exists and why that makes sense for you guys doing this since you're buddies and you wanna kind of spread that kind of buddy feeling in the process. It's a tough elevator pitch and I over talk and go on too long. So it's a bad comment. Sean will cut you off, don't worry.
你们在做什么，与现有的相比，为什么这对你们这些哥们来说很有意义，因为你们想在过程中传播那种哥们的感觉。这是一个艰难的电梯推销，我说话太多，时间太长了。所以这是一个糟糕的评论。肖恩会打断你的，别担心。
Basically what it is is like over the years, as I'm sure you have, we start to kind of know it. Like there's money that gets spent on things that don't end up making the movie any better. And the more money that you spend on what you do, the more obligation you have, the sort of more risk there is and the less likely people are to do things
基本上就是，多年来，我相信你也一样，我们开始有点了解了。就像有些钱花在了最终并没有让电影变得更好的事情上。你花在工作上的钱越多，你的义务就越多，风险就越大，人们做你认为更有趣的事情的可能性就越小，他们想变得更传统。然后我环顾四周，作为一个导演，我开始真正理解并重视那些对你正在做的事情的质量产生重大影响的剧组成员，无论是在速度方面还是在环境方面
that you consider more interesting and they wanna be more conventional. And then I looked around and I just, as a director, started to really understand and value the people on the crew who made such a significant difference to the quality of what you're doing, both in terms of speed and in terms of the environment
以及你能够表演的方式。我坚信表演最终才是吸引人们的东西，表演和剧本。所以我们想出了这个主意，从没想过会有人真的资助我们建立一个基于两件事的电影工作室。基本上允许剧组和艺术家，也就是编剧。
and the way in which you're able to perform it. I'm a big believer that the performance really ultimately is what draws people in and performance and the writing. And so we came up with this idea of never thinking anyone would ever actually fund us to do a movie studio that was predicated on two things. Basically allowing the crew and the artist being the writer.
我的意思是，我把剧组视为艺术家，也就是整个团队，演员、导演、编剧等等，以及摄影师、混音师，所有共同创造我们所做价值的人，以一种真正有意义、重要的方式从收益中受益，但也对此负责。换句话说，听着，如果超支了，
I mean, I consider the crew the artist, which is the whole group, actors, directors, writers, so on, as well as cinematographers, sound mixers, everybody who collectively create the value in what we're doing to benefit from the upside of it in a really meaningful, significant way, but also to be responsible for it. In other words, listen, if it goes over,
你会得到更少。如果低于预算，你会做得更好，但我们所有人都必须把它做好。否则我们什么也得不到，有点像把人当作成年人对待，相信他们可以负责，也相信因为激励机制在历史上并没有对齐
you're gonna get less. If it comes in under, you're gonna do better, but all of us have to make it good. Otherwise we're not gonna get anything and sort of treat people like grown-ups, believe they can be accountable and also believe that because incentives have not historically been aligned
在资助电影的人和制作电影的人之间。所以不深入细节，这个想法是，让我们把它分开，比如，电影的价值是什么？好吧，通常他们会使用比较。比如，预算是多少？你上一部电影赚了多少钱？
between the people financing movies traditionally and the people making them always. And so without going into too great a detail, the idea was like, and let's separate this out from, like what is the value of a movie? Well, usually they'll use comps. Like, well, what's the budget? And what did you make on your last movie?
尤其是现在，因为没有后端和总收入，就是这样，对吧？好吧，我一直觉得这就像走进苹果商店说，当你告诉我你付给组装它的人多少钱时，我会告诉你我给你多少钱买iPhone。但这不是它的工作方式，对吧？
And especially now, because there's no backend and no gross, that's sort of it, right? Well, I've always felt that was akin to going into the Apple store and saying, I'll tell you how much I give you for the iPhone when you tell me how much you paid the guy that put it together. But that's not how it works, right?
所以为什么它必须以另一种方式工作？因此，作为资助者和制片人，这个工作室，我们必须雇佣所有的商务事务、法律和物理制作等等，这样我们才能成为一个足够重要的实体，承担开发、制作、拍摄和交付电影的全部创意责任。
So why does it have to work in the other way? So by being agnostic as a financier and producer, this studio, we had to then hire all the business affairs and legal and physical production and so on so that we could be an entity significant enough to take on the entire creative responsibility of developing, producing, shooting, and delivering the movie.
作为交换，我们得说，看，这就是成本。它不会多花一分钱。如果超支了，我们来付。但你必须，我们要成为承担责任的人，承担说，我们要交付好东西的角色。如果它很糟糕，那是我们的错。
And in exchange, we got to say, look, this is what it's gonna cost. It won't cost a dime more than that. If it goes over, we pay for it. But you have to sort, we're gonna be the ones who take on the burden, the role of saying, we're gonna deliver something good. If it's terrible, it's our fault.
但你得信任我们能做到这一点。我相信无论我们与哪些合作伙伴合作，都有优秀的、才华横溢的人在发行和营销电影，我们不做那个。我们不想做太多电影，但我们只想和我们喜欢的人一起拍好电影。
But you are gonna sort of put your trust in us to be able to do this. I'm sure whatever partners that we work with, there are excellent, brilliant people with distributing and marketing movies, we don't do that. We don't wanna do very many movies, but we wanna just really make good movies with people we like.
我喜欢这个。就是这样。我们认为人们应该为他们所需要的得到更多报酬。所以你基本上是通过资助制作来承担财务风险。然后你说，我们不需要，你不需要通过给我们钱来制作它而获得杠杆融资，
I love that. And that's it. And we think people should be paid more for what they need. So you're basically taking on the financial risk by funding the production effectively. And then you're saying, we don't need, you don't get the leverage financier by giving us the money to make it,
假设我们没有钱制作它。我们实际上有。我们会花钱制作它。我们基本上是来找你说，我们想把这个产品卖给你。我们会处理批发部分。这是零售价。谁想买？
assuming that we don't have it to make it. We actually do. We're gonna spend the money to make it. And we're basically coming to you and saying, we'd like to sell you this product. We're gonna take care of the wholesale part. Here's the retail price. Who wants to buy it?
完全正确。是吗？完全正确。这很有道理。这就是他刚才说的。他刚才说的。我正在试着看看我的大脑是否听对了。我们马上回来。
Exactly. Yeah? Exactly. It makes a lot of sense. That's what he just said. He just said. I'm trying to see if my brain heard it right. We'll be right back.
我们部分由Zip Recruiter赞助。现在，听着，这个国家有很多生意在进行。这是我们热爱这个国家的原因之一，对吧？小企业，你可以，你可以走出去，如果你想要的话就去抓住它。但你需要的一件事是一个很棒的员工队伍。你需要很棒的人在你的公司工作。
We are brought to you in part by Zip Recruiter. Now, listen, there's a lot of business going on in this country. It's one of the things we love about this country, right? Small business, you can just, you can go out there and grab it if you want it. But one of the things you're gonna need is a great staff. You're gonna need great people working at your company.
Zip Recruiter，他们让找到最好的人变得非常容易，因为你知道吗？你在听吗？你应得的。你应得拥有很棒的员工。好吧，现在听着，脱颖而出很难，特别是如果你是一个企业主，你想吸引最有才华的人
Zip Recruiter, they make that very easy to find the best people because you know what? Are you listening? You deserve it. You deserve to have great employees. Okay, now listen, it's tough to stand out, especially if you're a business owner and you want to attract the most talented people
来你的团队工作。但Zip Recruiter让它变得容易。现在你可以免费试用，网址是ziprecruiter.com/smartlist。我说免费。Zip Recruiter如何帮助你在合适的候选人面前脱颖而出？他们的技术会为你发送很棒的候选人
to hire on your team. But Zip Recruiter makes it easy. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. I said free. How does Zip Recruiter help you stand out to the right candidates? Their technology sends you great candidates for your job
你可以向你的首选发送个人邀请。Zip Recruiter也让候选人申请你的工作变得容易。而不是填写冗长的申请表，他们只需点击一下即可申请。为了帮助你的工作吸引优秀候选人的眼球，Zip Recruiter还提供引人注目的标签，如远程、提供培训、紧急等。
and you can send a personal invite to your top choices. Zip Recruiter also makes it easy for candidates to apply to your job. Instead of filling out a lengthy application, they can apply with just one click. To help your job catch the eye of great candidates, Zip Recruiter also offers attention-grabbing labels like remote, training-provided, urgent, and more.
我的意思是，那非常引人注目。让你的工作被Zip Recruiter最好的候选人注意到。在Zip Recruiter上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就得到了高质量的候选人。自己看看吧。去这个独家网址免费试用Zip Recruiter，我说ziprecruiter.com/smartlist。
I mean, that's very attention-grabbing. Get your job noticed by the best and brightest candidates with Zip Recruiter. Four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free, I said ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist.
再说一遍，是ziprecruiter.com/S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。Zip Recruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。回到节目。所以现在，但一旦你完成了电影的制作，你现在必须进入另一件事，因为你要去找发行商。是的，所以你是在和所有不同的发行商合作，
Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S. Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. And back to the show. So now, but then once you have finished the completion of a film, you now have to enter into a whole nother thing because you're going out there to distributors. Yeah, so are you working with all different distributors,
所有不同的——是的，显然生意就像，有很多变化。你有流媒体，你有院线和流媒体的公司，所以，那是，还没人完全搞清楚。我的感觉是人们正在观看事物并对它们感兴趣，这将是持续的，
all different- Yeah, obviously business is like, there's all sorts of changing a lot. You have streamers, you have companies that are theatrical and streaming and so, and that's, nobody's quite figured that out yet. My feeling is people are watching things and interested in them and that's gonna be ongoing,
他们如何弄清楚他们在哪里放置价值的经济学。如果我们把重点放在几件事上，并努力把它们做好。而且，我真的只是觉得，有趣的原创剧、喜剧、各种想法开始从院线世界中消失了。是的。
how they figure out the economics of where they place value on it. If we keep our focus to a few things and try to make them really good. And also, I really just felt like, interesting original dramas, comedies, sort of ideas were starting to fall away from theatrical world. Yes.
我当时想，不，那不在电影院里。所以有了这部电影，这部电影的主题与这个业务的想法和理念是一致的。比如，人们值多少钱，他们应该如何得到补偿？而且这个故事本身，我认为很有趣。
I was like, nah, that's not in movie theaters. And so with this movie, and this movie's themes are kind of congruent with the ideas and the philosophy of this business. Like, what are the people worth and how should they be compensated? And isn't this the story itself, I think is interesting.
我希望人们去看这样的电影。是的，我看着，看着你的预告片，我第一次看到它时就想到了那件事，我想没有人能再拍这样的电影了，因为我们生活在一个世界里，每个人都在某种程度上受益并参与了这些，
I want people to go see movies like this. Yeah, I watch, watching your trailer, I thought that very thing, the first time I saw it, I thought nobody gets to make movies like this anymore because we've lived in a world where, and everybody has benefited and participated to a certain degree in these,
无论你称它们为什么，这些神庙或者这些——包括我。是的，不，这就是我的意思。每个人，我们所有人都以某种方式受益。然而，发生的事情是，结果就是你正在谈论的这些其他类型的电影——
sort of whatever you call them, these temples or these- Including me. Yeah, no, that's what I mean. Everybody, all of us have benefited in certain ways. However, what happened was, the result of that is that these other kinds of movies that you're talking about-
没有特效。没有特效，而且是以故事为驱动的，而且是——好吧，你的头发。但除此之外——是的。是的。那些东西真的，
Without special effects. Without special effects and that are story driven and that are- Well, your hair. But beside that- Yeah. Yeah. Those things don't really,
那种电影真的不再存在了。不在电影院里。哇。有3000个银幕，对吧？好吧，问题的一部分是他妈的《黑钱胜地》。是的，完全正确。因为过去，要放映一部电影，你是在竞争，比如《法律与秩序》或者什么，麦格农。
those kind of movies don't really exist as much anymore. Not in the theaters. Wow. There's 3,000 screens, right? Well, part of the problem is fucking Ozark. Yeah, exactly. Because it used to be that to put on a movie, you're competing, like Lawn Order or whatever, Magnum.
你知道我的意思吗？你有一个11英寸的黑白电视，你可以看《西蒙和西蒙》，或者你可以去看——好吧，你知道，1600年的更难。哦，我的天。现在，你有《继承之战》和《黑钱胜地》，还有他妈的真正好的东西，
You know what I mean? You had an 11-inch black and white and you could watch Simon and Simon, or you could go see- Well, you know, harder at 1600. Oh my God. And now, you've got Succession and Ozark and really good fucking stuff,
人们在家里说，你知道吗，我可以暂停，我可以明天看。这使得它变得非常困难。但看起来他们正在接近一个很好的组合，你在实体电影院里得到了一个很好的时间窗口。如果你想的话，你可以在大银幕上看到它。或者你可以等，是什么？
where people at home go, you know what, I can pause, I can watch tomorrow. That's made it very difficult. But it looks like they're approaching a good combo where you're getting a nice window of time in the Brick and Mortar theaters. You can see it on a big screen if you want. Or you can wait, what is it?
我想现在基本上是六周后它就会在你的家里，而不是旧的方法是三个月，而且它是——我真的很感谢亚马逊。他们第一次真正追求，我们要进行院线，传统的，你知道，3500个银幕在电影院里。
I think it's now basically six weeks before it'll be at your home, as opposed to the old method was like three months, and it was- I'm really grateful to Amazon. The first time they're really going for the, we're gonna do a theatrical, traditional, you know, 3,500 screens out in the theaters.
去看看吧。你等不及要免费看它了。就像，不是用一个即将到来的免费家庭版本来抢风头。这是亚马逊，对吧？是的，亚马逊，是的。他们真的在为此冒险。我真的，我的意思是，我希望它能成功，老实说，
Go see it. You can't wait to see it for free. Like, not sort of upstaging it with a very impending free version at home. This is Amazon, right? Yeah, Amazon, yeah. And they really are taking a flyer on this. And I really, I mean, I hope it works honestly,
显然是为了电影，但也为了我们可以再做一次。而且回到那个模式的原因，我们确实要求的一件事是，好莱坞模式有点像，我在失败中得到报酬，对吧？对。就像，我还有钱，我的意思是，我花了它，
obviously for the movie, but also so that we can do it again. And the reason why going back to that model, the one thing that we do ask is that like, the Hollywood model is kind of like, I get paid in failure, right? Right. Like, I still have the money, I mean, I spent it,
但我从《鸳鸯绑匪》中赚了钱。我不需要还回去。对。你知道我的意思吗？加上破产时，我有一辆车，你知道吗？所以这就像，我们在这里不会得到报酬。我们只是要花制作电影本身的成本。
but like, I made money on Geely. I didn't have to give it back. Right. You know what I mean? Plus when broke, and I got a car, you know? So this is like, we're not gonna get paid here. We're just gonna spend what it costs to make the movie itself.
我们都会出现并投入我们的时间和精力。如果它有效，如果它成功了，如果它在经济上成功了，你会得到报酬，无论你是摄影师，还是编剧导演，比你本来会得到的要多得多。但你如何得到补偿和你与观众的联系程度之间的关系是非常直接的
And we're all gonna show up and invest our time and energy. And if it works, and if it's successful, and if it's financially successful, you'll get paid whether you're the cinematographer, whether you're the writer's director, much more otherwise than you would have. But the relationship between how you're compensated and how much it connects to audiences is really direct
而不是仅仅像，嘿伙计，你知道，我不会为了少于什么而起床。这就是我有点，你知道，那和那种氛围真好，你知道，做这件事的人只是想在那里。而且我认为这部电影很有机会达到那种时代精神，
versus just like, hey man, you know, I don't get out of bed for less than whatever. And that's what I kind of, you know, that and such a nice thing to not have that vibe, you know, where the people who are doing it just wanna be there. And I think this film's got a real good chance of hitting that sort of zeitgeist thing,
只有两个原因。第一，这是一个我们都认为我们知道，但我们不知道的故事。关于耐克如何以及为什么在迈克尔·乔丹进入NBA时与迈克尔·乔丹做生意的整个故事。当这个运动鞋的整个开始，这个整个Air Jordan的事情，就像这是一个令人难以置信的美国商业故事
only for two reasons. Number one, it's a story we all think we know, but we don't. The whole story about how and why Nike got into business with Michael Jordan when Michael Jordan entered the NBA. And when this whole start of this sneaker, this whole Air Jordan thing, like it's an incredible American business story
没有人真正知道它是怎么组合在一起的。而这部电影，解释了它。而且你在疯狂三月期间发布它，我认为这是天才。而且首先，我听说它很棒，从几个看过它的人那里。其中两个在电影里，但他们说它很棒。相信他们。
that no one really knows how it went together. And this movie, explain it. And you're releasing it during March Madness, which I think is genius. And first of all, I hear it's great from a few different people who've seen it. Two of them are in the movie, but they say it's great. Believe them.
而且……顺便说一句，你可以随时来家里看它。我告诉杰伊，他没邀请你，因为我告诉杰森两三次，请，邀请他来。我想他在电话的那部分断开了。我非常想看它。而且我想布拉德利看了。
And... You can come by the house and watch it anytime, by the way. I told Jay, he didn't invite you because I told Jason two or three times, please, ask him to come. I think he broke up during that part of the phone call. I'm desperate to see it. And I think Bradley saw it.
总之，无论是什么，我非常想看它。我想这听起来太棒了。布拉德利不让我看这部电影，直到它混音完成。所以我认为那部电影很棒。我听了剧本，我记得对他说，就像，这就是那部电影。我们在谈论《音乐大师》。伙计，《音乐大师》。
Anyway, whatever it is, I'm desperate to see it. I think it sounds amazing. Bradley won't let me see this movie until it's mixed. So I think that movie's great. I heard the script and I remember saying to him, like, this is the movie. We're talking about Maestro. Dude, Maestro.
真的，是的。令人难以置信。而且测试，它太棒了。它他妈的太棒了，谈论没人拍的电影。这是我读过的最好的剧本。它真的，真的很好。但我本来想说，对于你的电影，很棒的是，
Really, yeah. Incredible. And the test, it's amazing. It's fucking amazing, talking about movies that nobody makes. It's the best script I've ever read. It's really, really good. But I was gonna say, for your movie, what's great is,
因为它确实是，就像杰森说的，它确实讲述了这个故事，而且它太棒了。像杰森这样的人，这就是他们学习东西的地方，从电影里，因为他们以前从没读过书。他们没有生活经验。对，他们没有生活经验。所以，但真的，每个人都说，
because it is, like as Jason says, it does tell the story and it's so great. And people like Jason, this is where they learn stuff is from the movies, because they've never read a book before. They have no life experience. Right, they have no life experience. So, but truly, everybody says,
甚至杰森也这么说，你从不说，你不是在谈论你自己，关于你有多爱这部电影。我可以肯定地说他确实爱它。所以，我很兴奋能看到它。现在，让我们谈谈蝙蝠侠。让我们谈谈每个人都说的真正的事情。我可以插一句吗？
and even Jason says this, which you never say, you weren't talking about yourself, about how much you love the movie. I can say that he legitimately loves it. So it's, I'm very excited to see it. Now, let's talk about Batman. Let's talk about the real thing that everybody's said there. Can I jump in here for a second?
让我们谈正事。嘿，肖恩。不，因为我们真正聚在一起的唯一一次是我们和吉米尔做关于蝙蝠侠的那件事的时候。然后我以乐高蝙蝠侠的身份探出头来。你们都嘲笑我。我觉得这很有趣。我们播客里确实有两个蝙蝠侠，肖恩。
Let's get down to business. Hey, Sean. No, because the only time we really hung out was when we did that thing with Kimmel about the Batman. And then I stuck my head in as Lego Batman. And you guys all laughed at me. I thought it was funny. We do have two Batman's on the podcast, Sean.
我知道，那很酷。非常酷。一个真实的，一个卡通的。但我看了《闪电侠》的预告片，当你出现在屏幕上时，每个人都疯了。你知道吗？那部电影很好。我听说它太棒了。
I know, that's kind of cool. It's very cool. One real and one cartoon. But I saw the trailer for The Flash and everybody was like freaking out when you came on the screen. You know what? That movie's good. I hear it's amazing.
那部电影真的很好。我听说那部电影他妈的很酷。他们让它变得真实。是的，我喜欢那个。这是我做过的最好的东西。我终于弄清楚怎么演那个家伙了。不，真的吗？真的吗？
That movie's really good. I hear that movie's fucking cool. They made it real. Yeah, I love that. And it's my best shit I've done. I finally figured out how to play the guy. No, really? For real?
我当时想，等等，是那个吗，我辞职了。我知道我辞职了。我知道我回来了，但我现在明白了。就像，你知道，你参加试镜，你在回家的路上，你就像，不。等等，那一刻是什么？什么，为什么真相大白了？发生了什么？
I was like, hold on, is that, I quit. I know I quit. And I know I came back to, but I got it now. It's like, you know, you do the audition and you're on your way home and you're like, no. Wait, what was the moment? What, why did the penny drop? What happened?
我的意思是，我不想剧透，但那是一个场景，我被，我在与一些坏人的冲突中被神奇女侠救了。她救了我，通过，我的意思是，我肯定我是像剧透一样，你知道，DC刺客。她以某种方式救了你。她用真言套索救了我。
I mean, I don't want to get a spoiler, but it was a scene where I got, I get caught, I get saved by Wonder Woman during a conflagration with some bad guys. And she saves me by, I mean, I'm sure I'm like the spoiler, you know, DC assassins. She saves you some way. She saves me with the lasso of truth.
所以发生的事情是蝙蝠侠泄露了，你知道，他对他生活和工作的一些真实感受。这有助于你看到这个角色，现在你想要另一个机会去演它。我当时想，等等，我明白了。我还在吗，我可以吗，伙计们？我们还在录吗？
And so what happens is that Batman divulges, you know, some of his real feelings about his life and his work. And it helps you see the character and now you want another chance to play it. I was like, wait a minute, I got it. Am I still, can I, guys? Are we still rolling?
所以发生的事情是，蝙蝠侠吐露了他对自己生活和工作的一些真实感受。这让你更了解这个角色，现在你又想有机会去扮演他了。我当时想，等一下，我明白了。我还，我还能吗，伙计们？我们还在录吗？
Can we write another scene? This is a story in my fucking life. By the way, Ben, one time I remember years ago, and I asked him about it. I remember Alec Baldwin saying in an interview that he was driving home from Nautzland when he was on Nautzlanding and like on a Friday night and just going like, oh fuck, that's how you do the scene.
我们能再写一场戏吗？这是我他妈生活中的一个故事。顺便说一下，本，我记得多年前有一次，我问过他这件事。我记得亚历克·鲍德温在一次采访中说，他在纳茨兰（Nautzland）拍戏时，周五晚上开车回家，当时他就在想，哦操，原来那场戏应该那样演。
And he's like, from that moment on, he made a deal with himself that he would never leave it, that he would always figure out the scene while he was there. And it always stuck with me, especially because it was Nautzland. It's so funny, Alec told me a similar story, but totally different.
他说从那一刻起，他对自己做了一个约定，他再也不会离开片场，他一定要在片场就把那场戏琢磨透。这句话一直印在我脑海里，尤其是因为那是纳茨兰。真好笑，亚历克也跟我讲过一个类似的故事，但完全不同。
Is that true? Yeah, he loves this metaphor. He's like, you know why I'm a good actor, but not a great actor. And I was like, no, Alec, and I don't want to answer that. It was like because I was playing Skowalski on Broadway. And he was supposed to leave the screen door. And I guess in some, and the screen door wouldn't open,
是真的吗？是的，他很喜欢这个比喻。他说，你知道为什么我是一个好演员，但不是一个伟大的演员吗？我说，不，亚历克，我不想回答这个问题。他说，因为当时我在百老汇演《欲望号街车》里的斯考斯基。他本该离开那扇纱门。我想在某种情况下，纱门打不开，
and he was exiting it, it wouldn't open. I shook it once, and I shook it twice, and it wouldn't open. And so I stepped around it, and right then, right then I realized what would Brando do. He would have kicked it down. He would have kicked it down. And I was like, so, oh, kick it down.
他正要走出去，门却打不开。我摇了一次，又摇了两次，还是打不开。所以我绕过它走了出去，就在那一刻，我意识到如果是白兰度会怎么做。他会把它踢开。他会把它踢开。我当时就想，哦，踢开它。
I don't know, oh, but he's very focused on that like moment after thing. Dude, that's hilarious. I want to ask you about, you've won two Academy Awards, Good Will Hunting and Argo Lighting. Thank you. I was wondering if we were going to get to that or let you into it.
我不知道，哦，但他非常专注于那种事后的时刻。伙计，那太搞笑了。我想问你，你赢得了两座奥斯卡奖，《心灵捕手》和《逃离德黑兰》。谢谢。我还在想我们什么时候能聊到这个，或者让你进入正题。
It's been the Jason Bateman show. Your publicist is like all over me about that. I was like, okay, got it. Texting, texting, texting. No, but I want to talk to you about Argo because he wrote me one of the funniest emails, which I want to read right now. We can cut it if you want, but it's really funny.
这简直成了杰森·贝特曼秀了。你的公关人员一直缠着我谈这个。我当时想，好吧，知道了。发短信，发短信，发短信。不，但我确实想和你聊聊《逃离德黑兰》，因为他给我写了一封最有趣的邮件，我现在想读一下。如果你愿意，我们可以剪掉，但它真的很有趣。
Anyway, Victor Garber, who's a friend of ours, right? He was staying in my guest house here while you were filming Argo. He said you were in his guest house, but go ahead. What's that? He said you were in his guest house, but he was in his guest house.
总之，维克多·加伯，我们的朋友，对吧？你拍《逃离德黑兰》的时候，他住在我这里的客房里。他说你当时住在他客房里，但你继续说。什么？他说你住在他客房里，但他住在他客房里。
Yeah, sure, whatever, we swap. We share, like you share a bank account, we share a guest house. So, I want to still share a bank account with Matt. All of a sudden the deal's over after born, you know. But you shot Argo three houses down for me and I would walk over to my pajamas
是的，当然，随便吧，我们交换了。我们分享，就像你分享银行账户一样，我们分享客房。所以，我还是想和马特分享银行账户。你知道，在《谍影重重》之后，交易突然就结束了。但你在离我三个房子远的地方拍《逃离德黑兰》，我会穿着睡衣走过去，
and sit down and watch you direct. And it was super, super fun. And then you won the Oscar and I was there at the Oscars. And I wrote an email to you and I said, I'm so proud of you, I'm so thrilled for you. I still, and then all the other sentences had question marks. I said, I still haven't seen it and I probably won't add to it.
坐下来看你执导。这超级超级有趣。然后你赢得了奥斯卡奖，我也在奥斯卡现场。我给你写了一封邮件，我说，我为你感到骄傲，我为你感到激动。我仍然，然后所有其他的句子都带了问号。我说，我还没看过，我可能也不会去看。
I'll probably have to Netflix it and someone will have to read the subtitles to me, but I'm sure I'll love it like everyone in Iran says they do. And then I said, I love your speech, blah, blah. And you wrote back, I saw your little sweet face when I was standing up there accepting my Oscar.
我可能得在Netflix上看，还得有人给我读字幕，但我肯定我会像伊朗的每个人说的那样喜欢它。然后我说，我喜欢你的演讲，等等等等。你回信说，当我站在那里领奖时，我看到了你那张可爱的小脸。
In the middle of the greatest triumph of my professional life, I thought, I have got to tell Sean to go tanning. I fucking, so when I was doing all this research for you today, like all this stuff, I found that old, I was like, I'm gonna look at old emails. I laughed out loud.
在我职业生涯最辉煌的时刻，我想，我一定要告诉肖恩去晒晒太阳。我他妈的，所以今天我在为你做所有这些研究时，像所有这些东西，我发现了那封旧邮件，我想，我要看看旧邮件。我大声笑了出来。
And then you wrote me another one. I haven't taken me up on it. Still, still pasty. No, not at all. I'm translucent. So good. Oh, Benjamin, this has been amazing. Way too much of your time.
然后你又给我写了一封。我还没接受你的建议。依然，依然苍白。不，一点也不。我是半透明的。太棒了。哦，本杰明，这太棒了。占用了你太多时间了。
Is it over? They told me it's two hours. So only an hour for me. It's two hours. You don't usually do it two hours. It just feels like two hours. Oh, great. It used to go three, right? I am a big fan.
结束了吗？他们告诉我这是两个小时。所以我只有一小时。这是两个小时。你通常不会做两个小时。感觉就像两个小时。哦，太棒了。以前是三个小时，对吧？我是你的忠实粉丝。
I gotta tell you guys, I love the Mark Maron show. You are wonderful. Oh, I'm sorry. Wrong show, wrong show, wrong show. Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit. No, the truth is you guys are, you guys do a great job. You managed to be very interesting to listen to.
我得告诉你们，我喜欢马克·马龙的节目。你们太棒了。哦，对不起。错的节目，错的节目，错的节目。哦操，哦操，哦操。不，事实是你们，你们做得很好。你们设法让听众觉得很有趣。
And yet very little of substance has ever said. We distract you with all the constant noise. That's all it is. It feels like, kind of wonderful. I enjoyed it. It's an honor and a pleasure to be on the show. Thank you for having me. Well, like, wonderful.
然而几乎没有说出什么实质性的内容。我们用不断的噪音分散你的注意力。就是这样。感觉，有点美妙。我很享受。能上这个节目是我的荣幸和荣幸。谢谢你们邀请我。嗯，太棒了。
You are honest to God, you are fucking amazing in the movie. From the first time I met you on the day of smoking aces, when I walked into that scene and you did the monologue about congenital alcoholism and herpes in a small penis, I have never, if you go back and watch that movie, there is not a shot of me when I'm not on the movie. That's not from the movie, dude.
你，说实话，你在电影里真是太棒了。从我在《五路追杀令》那天第一次见到你开始，当我走进那场戏，你表演了关于先天性酗酒、疱疹和小阴茎的独白时，我从来没有，如果你回去看那部电影，没有一个镜头是我不在电影里的。那不是电影里的，伙计。
He was just telling something weird. You were just hanging out, then, remember? He put it in the movie. He put it in the movie. It was, I was like, this guy is a genius of genius. And I have never forgotten it. And then it's just been a pleasure to work with you. No, no, your fault.
他只是在说一些奇怪的事情。你当时只是在闲逛，记得吗？他把它放进了电影里。他把它放进了电影里。当时，我就想，这家伙是个天才中的天才。我从来没有忘记过。然后和你一起工作一直是一种荣幸。不，不，是你的错。
Genius. Love, Joe. Great in that, great in extract. I have loved it. It's been my pleasure. We had fun on extract. I think you're a genius. Yeah, you are a genius.
天才。爱你的，乔。在那个电影里很棒，在《提取》里也很棒。我很喜欢。这是我的荣幸。我们在《提取》里玩得很开心。我觉得你是天才。是的，你是天才。
I do. I think all that you've got. My mother thinks that word's overused. Yeah, it is. She hears it a lot about her sons. But we're really happy, I will say this. I'm so happy that you're directing movies and you're making movies like this
我是这么认为的。我觉得你拥有一切。我母亲认为这个词被滥用了。是的，确实。她经常听到关于她儿子的这个词。但我们真的很开心，我得说。我很高兴你在执导电影，你在制作这样的电影，
and that you just continue to do fucking great stuff. Yeah, I can't wait to see it. I love it. This is all I want to do. You do want to direct more than act, right? You love it. You're so good at it. I started really loving acting finally for real
而且你继续做着他妈的伟大的事情。是的，我迫不及待想看它。我喜欢它。这就是我想做的全部。你确实想执导多过表演，对吧？你喜欢它。你很擅长。我终于开始真正喜欢表演了，
when I was like, I don't want to do this anymore. I'm just gonna direct movies. This is, I'm done with this. Right. I don't care. I just like directing. I was kind of like, well, I'm already here. And I can, you know.
当我当时想，我不想再做这个了。我只想执导电影。这就是，我受够了这个。对。我不在乎。我只是喜欢执导。我当时想，好吧，我已经在这里了。我可以，你知道。
Do them both, right? Act in the movies and be direct. And then I just let go. And I remember Sidney Pollock once saying, when we did, he was a director and an actor and we did a movie called Changing Lanes 20 some years ago. And he said to me, you know why I'm a good actor? I was like, no, no, no, Sidney Pollock.
两者都做，对吧？在电影里表演并执导。然后我就放手了。我记得西德尼·波拉克曾经说过，当我们做，他是一位导演兼演员，我们在20多年前拍了一部叫《连锁反应》的电影。他对我说，你知道为什么我是一个好演员吗？我说，不，不，不，西德尼·波拉克。
Cause I don't give a shit. Yeah. And I was like, I didn't understand at the time but I know what he's getting at now, which is that so much of it just has to do with letting go and being relaxed. And trying things and not sweating what people are going to think.
因为我他妈的不在乎。是的。我当时不明白，但我现在知道他在说什么了，那就是很多事情都与放手和放松有关。尝试一些事情，不要担心别人会怎么想。
And, you know, you know, trying the take that at the time Jason and Matt make fun of you for, but later on works in the movie. We know what we're talking about. Wait, really? Wait, which one was? It was the take where I really wanted to play my part and I interrupted Matt and made him wait a second.
而且，你知道，你知道，尝试那个当时杰森和马特嘲笑你的镜头，但后来在电影里却起作用了。我们知道我们在说什么。等等，真的吗？等等，哪一个？就是那个我真的很想演好我的部分，我打断了马特，让他等了一秒钟的镜头。
And you were like, maybe too big. Maybe that's too big. I said that? Uh-oh. No, I believe in the movie. Matt was right out in front of you. You were like, you can't do that. Hold on, hold on.
你当时说，也许太夸张了。也许那太夸张了。我说过吗？噢，不。不，我相信电影。马特就在你面前。你说，你不能那样做。等等，等等。
Oh, wait a second. Oh, wait, is this the one with the blaster glasses and the jogging outfit? Oh, no, you were all equivocal about that and that didn't make, that was too big. Dude, it's on the poster. What do you mean it didn't make the movie? You're on the poster in your phaser glasses
哦，等一下。哦，等等，这是那个戴着爆破眼镜和慢跑装的那个吗？哦，不，你对那个很含糊，那没有成功，那太夸张了。伙计，它在海报上。你是什么意思它没进电影？你戴着你的相位眼镜在海报上，
and your jumpsuit. That is historically accurate. I get it. That is taken from historical footage. No one's going to know that though. They're just going to be like, oh boy. I'm trying to promote it. Why?
还有你的连体衣。那是历史准确的。我明白了。那是取自历史镜头。但没人会知道这一点。他们只会想，哦天哪。我正在努力推广它。为什么？
That's what I'm hearing. The whole point was to get to the fact that that is not made up. That is the clothes that were worn. And his purple is purple Porsche. He had a purple Porsche that said Nike Man. This is film night listener. The guy who created Nike.
这就是我听到的。重点是说明那不是编造的。那是当时穿的衣服。还有他的紫色保时捷。他有一辆紫色保时捷，上面写着耐克人。这是电影之夜的听众。那个创造耐克的人。
I can't wait to see it. And I do, once I started doing it and doing it with people I really loved. And it's true, I would, I love directing in a different way but acting has become really fun. Tender Bar was really fun. Last tool was really fun. The Way Back was really fun, weirdly, for a movie about.
我迫不及待想看它。而且我确实，一旦我开始做这件事，并和我真正爱的人一起做。这是真的，我会，我以不同的方式喜欢执导，但表演变得非常有趣。《温柔酒吧》真的很有趣。《最后的工具》真的很有趣。《回归之路》奇怪地真的很有趣，对于一部关于
A person whose child dies and is alcoholic. You were awesome. It was like, it become joyful because I started developing my own criterion and stopped kind of making it about like, you know. As Will says, it's a sexy indifference, right Will? I don't say that, no. I'm going with overweight indifference.
一个孩子去世且酗酒的人的电影来说。你太棒了。这就像，它变得快乐，因为我开始发展我自己的标准，不再把它变成像，你知道。正如威尔所说，这是一种性感的冷漠，对吧威尔？我不那么说，不。我选超重的冷漠。
No. Indifference is attractive. Well, whatever you're doing, please keep doing it, man. Just such a fan. You're so great at what you do and you always have been. And just such a fan. Thank you very much. And I'm going to hold you guys to it. This is your all in the next one for free.
不。冷漠是有吸引力的。好吧，无论你在做什么，请继续做下去，伙计。真是个粉丝。你所做的事情非常棒，而且一直都是。真是个粉丝。非常感谢。我会让你们信守承诺的。这是你们下一次免费参与。
Thank you. Oh my God. Oh yeah. I told you the model. Yes, thank you. We'll do it for free. We'll just do it for the art. I thank you. You're amazing for doing this. I'm too handsome for film. Will you let me into the fucking octurtle battle or do I do my JV stuff?
谢谢。天哪。哦，是的。我告诉过你那个模型。是的，谢谢。我们会免费做的。我们只是为了艺术而做。我谢谢你。你做这件事真是太棒了。我太帅了，不适合电影。你会让我进入那个他妈的乌龟战斗吗，还是我做我的JV东西？
Tell Matt. Here it is. Yeah, give my agent your number. Yeah, I know. Okay, great. Does Matt own the invites? Yeah. He's the commissioner. So did he really keep you out?
告诉马特。在这里。是的，把我的号码给你的经纪人。是的，我知道。好的，太棒了。马特拥有邀请权吗？是的。他是专员。所以他真的把你拒之门外了吗？
I'll talk to him. Yeah, totally locked me out. Well, not even locked me out. He was like, maybe, maybe keep working. You know, maybe like that. Like out of luck for me. Try the cross work. He finally, I tell him this.
我会和他谈谈。是的，完全把我锁在外面了。好吧，甚至不是锁在外面。他就像，也许，也许继续努力。你知道，也许像那样。就像我运气不好一样。试试交叉工作。他终于，我告诉他这个。
This is inside. He finally won today for the first time in like six weeks and he was ecstatic. Really? Yeah. Yeah. He was having a tough time. But like I said, once I found out that he's in the low 50s, now I maybe I'm wondering if there is kind of an intramural
这是内部消息。他今天终于赢了，这是六周以来的第一次，他欣喜若狂。真的吗？是的。是的。他经历了一段艰难的时期。但就像我说的，一旦我发现他处于50多杆，现在我可能在想是否有一种校内
league that I can be. Because that is- You're feeling Ben's going to wax all you guys. Yeah, it won't take you long. Believe me, you're a sharp guy. It will not take you long to fucking make us all look like fools. I'm starting to lose it. Yeah.
联赛我可以参加。因为那是——你觉得本会打败你们所有人。是的，不会花你太长时间。相信我，你是个聪明人。你不会花太长时间让我们看起来像傻瓜。我开始失去它了。是的。
You are y'all young. Ginko. Ginko. Thanks guys. I have a question about Batman. Oh, sorry. Sure, sure, go ahead. No, no, no, no.
你们都很年轻。银杏。银杏。谢谢你们。我有一个关于蝙蝠侠的问题。哦，抱歉。当然，当然，请继续。不，不，不，不。
Feel free. Go ahead, call it. Ben, love you. Thank you for doing this. Yeah, I love you, pal. Very, very nice. Jason has my number and you guys honestly got like, the movie is here, sitting here on the projector.
请便。继续，说吧。本，爱你。谢谢你做这件事。是的，我也爱你，伙计。非常，非常棒。杰森有我的号码，你们老实说，电影就在这里，放在投影仪上。
And if you ever want to come at any point, even if I'm not here, it's like sitting up, bringing the bell, come watch the movie. You probably don't give a shit and you're going to end up, you know, watching it. No, no, no, they do. You live about three blocks from Will.
如果你想在任何时候来，即使我不在，它就在那里，按门铃，来看电影。你可能不在乎，你最终会，你知道，看着它。不，不，不，他们会的。你住在离威尔三个街区的地方。
Oh, wow. So someone has no excuse. No, no, we'll walk over. By the way, we will cut this, but I love the new house. Yeah. Thank you. Well, the rental is not too fucking shabby. Is that the one you're talking about, Sean?
哦，哇。所以有人没有借口了。不，不，我们会走过去。顺便说一下，我们会剪掉这个，但我喜欢新房子。是的。谢谢。好吧，租金并不太他妈的寒酸。肖恩，你说的是那个吗？
No, the one that they just purchased. Sean is keeping up with some of our celebrity journals. No, no, no, I have a real estate agent who's known. Oh. But yeah, and I saw it under construction and I was like, this is amazing. So I'd love to see it when it's done. You are the first to be invited.
不，他们刚买的那个。肖恩跟上了我们的一些名人期刊。不，不，不，我有一个认识的房地产经纪人。哦。但是是的，我看到它在施工，我想，这太棒了。所以我很想在它完成后看看。你是第一个被邀请的。
No, we heard it. We got it recorded. Thank you, Benjamin. We love you. Thanks for the rest of the night. Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you.
不，我们听到了。我们录下来了。谢谢你，本杰明。我们爱你。谢谢剩下的夜晚。非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Bye, bud. Wow. Well, that guy, I mean. Fucking wattage. So when we were talking about. Big star wattage. I mean, we had Damon on tour and that's fine.
谢谢。再见，伙计。哇。好吧，那家伙，我的意思是。他妈的魅力。所以当我们谈论时。大明星魅力。我的意思是，我们有达蒙在巡演，那很好。
Matt was fine. But then we have Ben, athletic. And just coming in with a fucking wattage. And you're like, well, that's the reason. Now that's a star. That's a star. Yeah, through outer space. Yeah.
马特很好。但后来我们有本，运动型的。带着他妈的魅力进来。你会想，好吧，这就是原因。那才是一个明星。那是一个明星。是的，穿过外太空。是的。
Yeah, through outer. You're not like, remember if fucking Matt showed up in like a fucking hoodie and he fucking, you know what I mean? I just get through the interview. Just get through the thing. And then Ben shows up and he's handsome. He's talented and he's smart as fuck. He's prepared.
是的，穿过外太空。你不是像，记得如果他妈的马特穿着连帽衫出现，他他妈的，你知道我的意思吗？我只是完成采访。只是完成这件事。然后本出现了，他很帅。他很有才华，而且他妈的聪明。他准备好了。
And he's prepared. And he's like, there's gorgeous. Yeah. Hang on a second. Jason, let me see your hands real quick. I want to see your hands while you're talking. Because it's really dark where you are. No, all jokes aside, wow, that was awesome.
而且他准备好了。他就像，那里很华丽。是的。等一下。杰森，让我快速看看你的手。我想在你说话时看看你的手。因为你那里真的很暗。不，撇开玩笑不谈，哇，那太棒了。
Yeah. And when I was doing like the research, you know, learning about him and stuff and about his past and whatever, I was like, and then you go through his credits, you're like, wow, you forget like, wow, bang, bang, bang, hit after hit after hit after hit. He's been so relevant and talented and successful for so long. And I feel like he's only halfway done.
是的。当我做研究时，你知道，了解他之类的事情，关于他的过去等等，我想，然后你浏览他的作品，你会想，哇，你忘记了，哇，砰，砰，砰，热门之后又是热门。他一直如此相关、有才华且成功了这么久。我觉得他才完成了一半。
Yeah. And I think, I don't know if this is true. Does anybody know it? Didn't he, hasn't he played Batman more than any other actor? I'll bet. I think that that might be, I think he might be right. Yeah. I think so.
是的。而且我想，我不知道这是不是真的。有人知道吗？他不是扮演蝙蝠侠次数最多的演员吗？我敢打赌。我觉得这可能是，我觉得他是对的。是的。我想是的。
He's played it five times, I think. Really? It's just, I'm so happy for him. This movie, he just, he crushes it and Matt and him did a great job writing a lot of stuff too. He's such a natural as a director. I mean, Jason, it's kind of what you talk about when you spend all that time doing it
我想他演了五次。真的吗？这只是，我为他感到高兴。这部电影，他简直太棒了，马特和他也在写作方面做得很好。他作为导演真是个天才。我的意思是，杰森，这有点像你花所有时间做这件事时谈论的内容
and you've got a head on your shoulders and you spend all that time on set and in that environment. Yeah. You've got to absorb something. You absorb something and you can kind of apply it. And he, you have done it and he has done it and he's made so many great films, as you said. Sean. Sean.
而且你头脑清醒，你花所有时间在片场和那种环境中。是的。你必须吸收一些东西。你吸收了一些东西，你可以应用它。而且你，你已经做到了，他也做到了，他制作了许多伟大的电影，正如你所说。肖恩。肖恩。
No, no, no, I know. But what was the one about Iran, the hostages? Argo. Argo. So Argo, the town is amazing as well. That's another great film that he directed. Yes, the town. I love that movie.
不，不，不，我知道。但关于伊朗，人质的那部是什么？《逃离德黑兰》。《逃离德黑兰》。所以《逃离德黑兰》，那个小镇也很棒。那是他执导的另一部伟大的电影。是的，《城中大盗》。我喜欢那部电影。
Really, really good. That's what I'm saying. I didn't even get a chance to talk to him about the town. That was so good. I know. Well, because you were asking too many questions about at a left field. He just texted me.
真的，真的很好。这就是我所说的。我甚至没有机会和他谈论《城中大盗》。那太好了。我知道。好吧，因为你问了太多关于左外野的问题。他刚给我发短信。
I hate Sean. Mm-hmm. Well, he's spelt at S-H-A-W-N, but the hate is spelt correct. No way. No, that's not true. No, he's the guy. My God.
我讨厌肖恩。嗯。好吧，他拼写为S-H-A-W-N，但仇恨拼写正确。不可能。不，那不是真的。不，他是那个人。天哪。
What an interesting lot. I'd like to read his book. I want to read his book. I want to read Downey's book. Um... Just a book. Any book would be great. I guess, right?
多么有趣的一群人。我想读他的书。我想读他的书。我想读唐尼的书。嗯……只是一本书。任何书都会很棒。我想，对吧？
It would be amazing at this point. It's top to bottom, left to right. Right? Yeah, as long as the book has a... Bye. Bye. Ding, ding, bye. And I turn.
在这一点上会很棒。它是从上到下，从左到右。对吧？是的，只要书有一个……再见。再见。叮，叮，再见。然后我转过身。
Those pages are bound. That works. Oh, no, he doesn't even know what I'm saying. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by
那些页面是装订好的。那行得通。哦，不，他甚至不知道我在说什么。聪明。最后。聪明。最后。SmartList是100%有机的，由
Bennett Barbicot, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf. Smart. Last. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free
本内特·巴比科特、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆朱夫手工制作。聪明。最后。我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者提前且无广告
by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中的Wondery Plus。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。